things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in King how many
likes to open up the chat today 1500 a
thousand five hundred likes and we'll
open up the chat and over how many
dollars of super chats are we reading 25
okay over 25 super chats we are reading
today so if you have a question for the
panel a comment concern feel free to
leave a Super Chat we're trying to save
for a kickout cam which we are not gonna
have to use today because everyone's
gonna have to get along right yeah yeah
um okay so before we start make sure you
subscribe to our two clips channels just
pearly clips and pearl daily
um and sign up for our Google form um
that way you're going to be notified
when we do events in London and in the
US so today we have a lovely panel so
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself yourself
so name age relationship status fun fact
oh my God hi I'm Marabella
um I'm 25
and a fun fact about myself oh my god um
I could fold my tongue in half
oh wow so there you go
next next hello
Kimmy K I'm 35.
um a fun fact about me
um I've got Tourette Syndrome so I
apologize in advance if anything comes
out of my mouth it shouldn't
I'm Deanna I'm 28 and I spend most of my
time gaming
I'm Layla Lazelle I'm 25 and I spend
most of my time with my dog he's a
Chihuahua and he's called Theo
I am Lola I am 29 I'm single and a fun
fact about me
I can do really good dog impression
you have to do it now can we hear it
yeah okay everybody be prepared I
haven't done this in such a long time
that's actually I'm impressed actually
surprisingly good my throat really hurts
I used to do that all the time when I
was little like at the door
scare away strangers I think you're my
new favorite person
I'm Sterling Cooper I am 36 uh fun fact
about me I guess is that I'm a retired
adult film star and a sex coach now all
right
me yeah you
uh yeah John Bernard keru's uh I'm 26
single uh fun fact about me comedian
from Australia but uh yeah not not
scared to be opinionated
my name is Andy Lee I'm single I'm 35.
um I was on a TV show for having a
massive [__]
wait really how big are we talking
why would how would they know that like
what kind of TV show was that was that
called my massive [__]
[Laughter]
you're lying no way thank you I'll get
out right now
okay okay not on YouTube
all right all right so
um today we are talking about do modern
women deserve sympathy
um so
my question actually I kind of wanted to
start a little I'll get to this part
later but what is a [__]
starting here
why is it always me well you just it's
just you're in the this is the starting
nobody told me where I was
um what is a hall
um a woman who gets I think dictionary
definition is literally a woman who gets
paid for sexual intercourse isn't it oh
yeah I'd agree yeah yeah same I mean if
that's what the dictionary says I can't
argue with that okay I don't know I
don't have a dictionary in my ass
I would just say oh the definition a
prostitute okay yeah someone who
exchanges money money for sex yeah okay
yeah I'd say the same I'd say yeah money
for sex but don't I wouldn't rely on the
dick
the the definition from a dictionary
it's what do you think it is so I would
say yeah a woman that sells herself
online or exchanges money for sex oh
okay what do you think it's a label used
mostly these days for women who have sex
with lots of people
okay so I was thinking about this and I
was thinking about the like the insults
we use right which it's [__] [__] and
hoe what is the I want to know what is
the difference between these three is
there any difference or are they all the
same I'd say they're all the same and
just different ways to
say it yeah I think it depends on where
you are though because if you're in the
gay community all of them are good
things like really yeah they're like oh
yeah how are you like do you know what I
mean like calling people by those things
are good things if you're in like an
LGBT space but then anywhere else yeah
no it's a bad thing it depends on the
way that they say it but I'll tell you
the way the average man uses it yeah in
a way like the average guy uses it it's
usually behind me like a [__] it's
probably right here a [__] probably a
girl has slept with him like Loosely a
[__] and a hoe is a girl that didn't
want to sleep with him but slept with
somebody okay yeah it's the anger it's
the anger that comes out when so
somebody comes up to a bar and they're
like trying to buy you drinks to sleep
with you and you're fully like I don't
want to sleep with you the anger is the
hoe and the [__] yeah and then or the
word which starts with a B which I
probably shouldn't say yes yeah let's
not do that Pearl show you can say it
you can say [__]
what's out what I thought oh my God
she's turning to a teacher yes yes my
kind of videos
I wanted to do was I really wanted to
start categorizing and getting specific
between [__] [__] and hoe
kind of autism
nowadays right we hear everyone saying
you're a [__] [__] hoe and I'm like
what is the definition anymore so I
decided
I wanted to know first of all which one
of these is the worst I want to label
them from like best to worst I would say
I would say whole I would say [__] yeah
because slot well who the fox says hope
but everyone calls out everyone calls
out it's like shaming how come there's
no horse shaming or oh yeah because
horse like an actual job no yeah I feel
like [__] is like biblical it's like
what they used to say it's like Jack the
Ripple size but I'm pretty sure if you
look at a thesaurus
um anywhere after two things that's why
we didn't care about dictionary
I'm pretty sure they're probably
interchangeable it's just one you could
just say you could say if you want to
say it was a worker but I need just for
for okay who thinks who thinks horror is
the worst one yeah I mean I feel like it
just seems so hard I would I would say
[__] I would vote that no more so what
we got three votes because we gotta
decide as a group again
all right all right three votes for
[__] who thinks [__] is
okay so two
some of you didn't even vote I think
some of you didn't vote
I would not be offended if I was called
a slot or a hoe slot you would all right
yeah I'm gonna put [__] is the number
one insult because I think that was the
most votes all right who thinks [__] is
a worse insult me I'd say [__] yeah okay
really so who says Ho I said ho okay so
I think [__] is second ho so since we
have so many nice ladies
I know you don't believe that
you would be nice you know but you guys
do you know do some only fans yeah I
wanna I was curious in the sex work
industry is there a hierarchy of sex
work like in terms of sluttiness and I
just wanted to know because I'll always
have the strippers come on here and
they'll be like well we're not as bad as
the only fans yeah so I wanted to know
all right what would you guys consider
yourselves [__] [__] oh are nice ladies
so I don't actually so the thing is with
all of these words there's something
that people will pay to tell you that
you are these people like you basically
are reenacting this I don't particularly
like being called any of those uh and
whoever calls me a hoe why because that
word doesn't even exist
um but I wouldn't say that I was a nice
lady because obviously I do very nasty
things but when you talk about the
hierarchy of only fans like obviously
when it comes to any fans there's a lot
of things that you can't do but there
are a lot of women who do Break The
Rules so we can we can clarify like like
only fans with bikinis we can we can go
into the like the yeah okay we can go
into the nitty-gritties with it I just
want to get some clarity here well yeah
and I added two different words if you
guys want to add some you know I would
say like for men yeah I don't think you
would ever call an only fans go a nice
lady okay
I think I'm only crossing my legs
because I'm on YouTube okay so all right
let's let's start with stripper what is
a stripper
a dancer for money
we're gonna we're gonna go with all the
women nice lady yeah strippers have we
found most strippers jackpot is aren't
nice ladies I used to do shopping we are
nice ladies I would say a strip as a hoe
okay because I feel like that word means
nothing it's got no conviction it's just
it should be like
I'll completely disagree with you about
the whole definition there why why I
think hoe is here because obviously you
guys are from Australia but I've lived
in America for the last five years okay
so Jose yeah it's an American thing yeah
in England we don't talk about like I've
never ever you might use the word slag
because
[Music]
you know I was called to slag by a whale
once yeah
started also guys we have a new patreon
group called whale watchers
if you want to lose weight I'm
sponsoring two fat chicks in England I
have one spot taken I really oh my God
that would have been me like three years
ago yeah everyone says I'm so mean
but I actually I actually am paying for
all their personal training and
nutrition the next three months there's
a three thousand dollar prize at the end
of it
whale watching that's amazing anyways
but it did the whale escapades did start
with the her calling me a slag that's a
whole nother doing God's work Bill thank
you
do charity I like to give back by paying
for personal training
I want to go
with the girl which one the the
okay she's so nice I like her yes good
on it I'm sorry but she's taking it
she's taking the opportunity she did
take it yeah I would I I yeah so you
want to do it well join with Watchers
join it you can now okay okay I'm sorry
we got to go back sorry
I need a show of hands as a stripper a
[__] no yes I would say yes yes I'm
gonna say yes I'm gonna say yes because
she like the way I separate these four
categories in my mind
the whole is doing things for money
the [__] is doing it for sex the hoes
doing it for attention and the nice
ladies doing it for love
[Music]
he's officially a [__] because she's
doing things for money did you say you
specialize in relationships no sex so
that was that was a great analogy yeah
all right money depends money sex
attention and then love attention Okay I
know I have bad handwriting but you guys
are just gonna have to deal okay that's
okay Mommy and then
here we go
[Laughter]
all right all right so so by this Logic
the stripper is a [__]
um
let's let's be honest quite a lot of
strippers will do things in the strip
club before I don't think so I don't
think so I'm not talking I'm not naming
names I'm not pointing anyone
who here has been to a strip club tell
on yourself yeah
have any of you been offered sex at the
strip club no no no no I'm asking
are you the ladies I'm bisexual okay but
you know the men are the ones that are
gonna pay for it
that's crazy that's crazy to me though
I've been in Vegas definitely seen that
in Prague definitely seeing that well
obviously baby you're splashing cash
around I'm pretty sure it's gonna be
awesome in Glasgow sorry guys I'm gonna
make the executive decision stripper is
a [__] that's fine
does after one one night stand is she a
[__]
she's can she still be a nice lady this
is an important definition this is I
think it's very important it's very
important is a one-night stand or a
first day lay those are two different so
one night stand is she [__] the guy and
then she never tries to see him again my
type of girl but her first night like a
first day lay is she [__] him on the
first date but she but they keep they
keep getting and keep saying are they
gonna keep dating or does he have no
opportunity to [__] her again is it like
a situation
I have a question I don't think there's
ever a woman's decision
so they're gonna think that a guy is
interested in them even though they're
not so is it that situation where a guy
isn't interested or is it because
otherwise if she if she's in the
situation where she thinks it's going to
go further and he knows it's not and
it's a one night stand to him and it's
not to her that's gonna not make her a
slightly that'll make her a nice girl if
not
situation number one she got she goes
out
man they do the dirty you know he's very
nice you know
let's just say he's a nice I don't know
what the musician bartender whatever
okay now now what are you saying you you
can say I don't care I don't I don't
know
okay okay
right so first night she sleeps with him
they never talk again is she a [__] a
[__] a hoe and or a nice lady how often
does she do that though it depends on
her intention doesn't it no but it
depends on how often she does it okay if
she does it once is she a [__] a [__]
or a hoe for life or can she still be a
nurse is she is she I hope it's romantic
like we need a little bit of a
backgrounds
between both of them what if it's a
mutual decision between people yeah yeah
it's a mutual decision they meet sleep
together don't speak oh she's nice she's
nice it depends what part she goes now
she could still be nice yeah
I'm saying once one time oh she's still
a nice lady or is she one of the three
leave her alone she's a nice lady I just
think every lady is more often than not
if you're [__] after the you know
meeting some guy on a night out you're a
[__] more often than not I would say 90
of the time oh yeah it depends on how
many times you've done it if you if you
go out and you are continuously [__]
guys with no intention of actually doing
anything oh my gosh there's so many men
in here oh my gosh okay guys
I want to know what the guys think raise
of hands one time is she a is she a
[__]
raise your hand no no okay she is slight
raise your hand yeah it's no if there's
no there's no attempt for like anything
else okay is she a hoe one time
all right does anyone think she's a nice
lady yeah I think she's a nice lady she
sounds really sweet it's only six okay
yeah yeah it's just sad and do these
like terms like go with guys as well all
right you know what I I'm gonna I'm
gonna
okay raise of hands who says nice lady
we're gonna go all right
rigged election
who says slime yeah I'll say [__] oh
all right I'm gonna you guys are getting
your dicks out too you know
she's a nice lady but she has [__]
tendency yeah and that's perfectly fine
not personally no it doesn't don't
confuse this with my dead person it just
means yeah maybe a worse person no yeah
Blog has good game yeah
sitting there telling you he's gonna
you're gonna they're gonna live their
life together okay okay so all right
it's still her decision to open her legs
it's always her decision at the end
for the guys is it different if she
thinks it'll be like a multiple night
stand 100 then it's not 100 yeah totally
agree yeah if a guy gives off the
impression because there are so many
vulnerable women out there who who
literally
correct it sounds awful but they are so
stupid that they think that they're
gonna have more than one night with one
guy and they'll sit there eating up all
the [__]
Brown didn't call me back
it's like watching it's like watching an
episode of MTV Catfish and you're just
sitting there like girl you are stupid
like you are dumb and that's okay okay
so we got strippers here all right now
ladies only fans with with sex on it I
must say [__] my best friends what do
you what do you mean with sex on it like
like she's banging a dude yeah
no I don't know I wanna know so it's
different if it's her boyfriend or a
different like just another I'm still
over there I still say [__] okay if it's
her boyfriend or only fans banging her
boyfriend [__] yeah
how it just work give me all three Pearl
give me horse [__] and Hope
fully I just don't like the work I don't
like the word hoe I think it's stupid it
sounds like childish all right for out
of out of the kindness of my heart I'll
just put it under horn [__]
hoe is in every single piece of music
that's on yeah but that's why it's like
fantastic
Kanye said he loved it you're such a
funny stupid yeah
and I'll go back to my original
definition it's a rake that goes into
the ground right because the hoarders
hoarders it for money so it does it for
sex or pure sexual gratification yeah
right Holiness of retention nice ladies
Beloved the hoe the reason why I said
the hoe is the one I I ranked the lowest
is because she's
putting her in her body and everything
out there
purely for the attention and validation
of men yeah not to create a loving bond
with a partner not for even if I would
respect a a genuine prostitute more than
a hawk because at least she's doing it
for a financial gain at least she's
buying some business sense to it yeah
right the whole the hoe who's like oh
yeah I'll go on Chris Brown's boat all
over the phone and shake and twerk my
ass and get my tits out and run around
like how do I respect that well to that
point I think only fans girls can be in
either of those categories like you said
they could be a hoe yeah
Earth has to lean more towards the the
whole Spectrum well yeah because there's
money yeah
for the love of being an only fans girl
and not for the money
actually hold on I actually
I'm really passionate about being an
only fans go here me do you love your
job I love her
like how some people like a nine to five
you know like some people really love
Finance I love chatting to new people
I love some parts of it but not really
fun yeah there's there's certain things
there's so I think I wouldn't post my
content
what do you guys think the average only
fans model makes in a year 140 yeah
it's under 300 a month yeah no it's 100
it's 180 a month the number the average
of the number yeah the number I have is
2 400 a year yeah that's yeah
so knowing that then aren't they really
not doing it for money
[Laughter]
I think the majority is is that a lot of
people have found out about this
referral scheme in America they use it a
lot and it's a pyramid scheme so all it
is is other girls telling how much girls
and how much money they make which in
reality you're not going to make money
off of people trying to make money
because if you don't want to work for it
you won't [__] get it so that's just
the way it works and a lot of girls
think they can just come into the
industry make loads of money and then
when they don't they kick off and quit
only fans because they and then what's
like it online and then they flag it off
it's like because you couldn't do it
that's all okay so they've been deluded
into yeah the trick of oh it's easy
money exactly I mean you guys you know
you make big money you make money all
you do like it ain't it's a job
it's still wise some degree
to make their kind of money the average
person couldn't do it without some
degree of Business Systems exactly and
like help like
putting on my piano
and I'm just like I'm just trying to be
as objective as I can about this like
having having been in in
you know that's the thing certainly you
don't think it's easier than other jobs
like go go away
get on an oil rig
I love bringing up the oil right
you think only fans is harder than an
oil rig definitely having sex on camera
is harder than being because you're not
thinking about yourself
right how the [__] are people going to
see you having sex on camera unless you
promote it exactly so it's the same as
usual YouTube promoting stuff online is
harder than being in the oil regions
I guess I need you I need you to go one
at a time yeah I'm not talking about the
oil rig I'm talking about so obviously
you do Sports content I also do some
sports content so how the [__] are
people going to see you on only fans
unless they actually see your normal
content so the majority of people who do
only fans have to do some sort of normal
content in order to exchange for money I
understand that obviously if you're
doing stuff on YouTube and that it's
hard to make money in it I'm sorry no
being a content creator is not that hard
when you say controversial [__] all the
time like yeah obviously it's very easy
to get views look look oh my God we're
gonna oh come on you couldn't build this
I feel like that's the that's the mental
side of it as well like there's a lot of
stigma and there's a lot of people that
give you hate every single day
you do have to deal with the mental
Battle of it as well all right I need to
go back to this so only fans [__] only
fans okay so only fans with um with
random men where does that go is that
like the lowest tier of only fans yeah
yeah if you're if you're just picking up
random men off the street to [__] them
one only five well maybe maybe look at
the rules maybe like other porn star I
don't know how it works
you can't you can't have sex with random
people on any fans but you can do
okay you do collapse so
um where does that fall [__] [__] or
hoe I would say you're a hoe well I I
don't like that word but I'm gonna put
you there
oh I can fit in our tree it doesn't
matter it's only business yeah
there's no Mutual I mean they're still
trying to earn money from it as well but
they're it's also [__] and it's also
been a home I think you could really put
it in okay you know what I I'd agree
with that part because like if she's
doing it not just for money but she also
like like she's going after the thrill
of just multiple multiple sexual
experiences
how many how many bodies does it take
how much all right so what let's I would
love to just break this down little by
little so all right and I need I need
the men to answer them this is like the
misconception though so so wait I need I
need to do so five all right two bodies
there's a woman still a nice lady yeah
definitely so you would call me a nice
lady then because I've literally slept
with two people even though I do of no I
think the oaf would cancel it
[Laughter]
you're a Christian like if you take it
from a Christian lens I'm a Catholic a
Catholic so if you're a Catholic if
you're looking from a Catholic lens then
anyone that has sex before marriage is
being careless and that's kind of [__]
almost okay okay so you would put are
you a Christian oh yeah I'm Catholic as
well oh nice I'm Catholic too boys
trying to get a general consensus
because if we go by historical point of
view you know you're right actually only
five percent of women would not be
classified as [__] because
virginity was a prerequisite for
marriage but I want to know in the
modern times with modern people right
I'm not saying this is right but I want
to know when is a woman clarified so two
bodies still a nice lady okay
yeah
um five bodies I'd say under five yeah
getting up there with five I reckon
Pearl five like in a lifetime or
whatever yeah
yeah okay oh my God okay ten bodies
it's getting excessive I mean that's a
lot of bodies
that much 10 is not that much
all right so the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 30 31. a 31 year
old woman 10 bodies nice lady yes or no
I want hands yes nice lady nice 10. now
she's married yeah nice lady no no he
thinks she's nice no not a nice lady at
31. yeah 31 10 bodies come on yeah I
mean it's that
age is a big thing to consider yeah it's
like no she might have been trying to be
the nice lady for the whole what was
yours when you when guys from 18 to 31
yes he's trying to say she's a [__]
should we add in another
characterization yeah we need another
one material yeah we need desperate I
think we need desperate on there because
there is like I think there's a big
differentiation between all of them we
need someone who's desperate because it
does come down to that I don't know what
you mean like Pastor Prime yeah not
pasta Prime but I think there's just
genuine generally just people who are
just desperate like someone else doesn't
matter how old they are someone who
tries too hard
no but it doesn't matter
there are some girls that genuinely try
they do too much they do too much and
you're like what and they're not even in
a category they are just above and
beyond okay so I put lady so nice lady
lady hoe [__] [__] that makes sense so
so 10 bodies [__] where is she
she's a lady lady yeah
five to ten is the ladies she's the lady
tonight
right all right what is the average like
amount of sexual party so I've actually
researched yeah no okay I'll tell you so
it's very confusing when you look at the
numbers because you know women were so
honest
yeah it's self-reported it says five to
eight however there are women in college
that report sleeping with seven sexual
partners in a year and 70 of women admit
to lying about their body count so
you'll never know good girls yeah but
why do you think you're categorizing
people into into slot hole that's not
why it's because women women and women
understand fundamentally that
the the male species will value her less
as a long-term potential partner when
you did only fans yeah but yeah but men
were in a very very different honey 100
very very different yeah that man's a
stud because he's [__] lots of chicks
because it takes him effort it takes me
effort you can literally you could
literally walk out the door right now
and be like wanna [__] [__] we want to
get a [__]
look at how big his dick is
the random lady outside and make it
happen instantly because we value what
takes effort yeah
but then if you did that then you'd
better started
very different life
I never got invited on any boats between
the ages
I love that for you and I would love to
suck your dick
that's the difference
really simple but I agree with this
point guys will look at girls with a
high body can and say okay
some guys don't I wouldn't care
I don't like I don't like
they've always had them in history yeah
so okay so five to ten lady
um 15.
um might as well just stop talking about
it
[Laughter]
there's a difference between a good
person and a nice lady a nice a person
could still be nice with a higher body
cam but doesn't necessarily make she's a
good person you know what I mean so I'll
tell you like men don't actually like
guys who actually sleep with women don't
sit there and do the math yeah exactly
we don't do that because it's like it
act the number really sort of ruined
your whole point here bill but the
number the number actually doesn't
matter at all never it's the behavior
she exhibits towards you yeah
if you change the point to nice lady or
lady for marriage then then the number
does Matt then the number does matter oh
right like
exactly
yeah
not necessarily why so you got one girl
for the rest of your life
it's worked for the last couple thousand
years I would say why it would stop
working
people people just finding a soul mate
and having kids settling down I think
I like that I don't I like that I added
one
so 15 is when she gets to be a hoe right
15. oh that's young Pearl geez yes
let's keep it legal 15 bodies we'll just
do 15 plus okay
now now I like this game now so we got
the strippers the only fans did we miss
any sex workers in here
escorts where do they I actually want to
hear from the ladies where would you put
the escort so if the hoe is attention
escort sex it's got to be [__] isn't it
if you're saying that it's money
um yeah yeah but it's not up to him if
you decide where she is well I wouldn't
know anyone else
so ask escort and then um hooker like
actual hooker is that like the lowest in
the sex world it's I think a lot of
people do judge escorts I mean there's a
lot of people who do only fans as well
who are escorts and the amount of people
that won't work with escorts on only
fans because they are escorts it's very
high yeah they get the most I know some
girls that go bareback for an extra 20
quid for escorting and I'm like I would
never work with you I'm so sorry however
there are some escorts obviously
escorting can be safe
and the way that you do it is very
professional but there are some people
who are just crackers like and you're
like absolutely not okay so it's
different levels so what I'm hearing I
wish I bareback for extra 20. I'm
hearing
110. absolutely
not oh
wait I'm sorry I didn't I didn't think
this through no it's okay well I didn't
think I could I thought it would I
thought I don't know maybe wifey
material will be small enough but that
split that in half yeah make that tiny
you know what I think the requirements
for the wifey material are probably the
biggest yeah I know I don't want to hear
about it but we're not talking on that
side they're talking about the other
side
it'll be the tiniest tonight
yeah I feel like the wifey material list
will be like the same [__] it's a
different day we need like yeah we need
we need to talk about this sort of stuff
to make it fun yeah we all know what a
wife is we just need to know
it's like we're talking about the
neurotypical Spectrum Maslow's hierarchy
for horse it's giving pyramid scheme
it's fine but the wifey material is like
the boring person and then the men go
and find the Halls anyway
you're basing that judgment purely upon
some kind of stuff if she's only had sex
with one person that's wifey material
but what if what if she like I'm taking
the female argument here what if she has
an amazing personality
I mean I mean in the bedroom I mean
why are we going directly okay I mean
anyway all right so we need because
obviously
okay thank you hookers at the bottom
right down above okay so above is would
we put only fans or strippers I would
say strippers really oh really no I did
it myself
definitely okay I've done it myself and
it was horrible and I went straight back
since all right we're gonna have to do
hands would you round all right only
fans is lower than strippers raise your
hands up for sure all right strippers is
lower than only fans raise your hand
our only fans are here next depends what
they do for a 20. only fans strippers
because strippers can be localized you
know only fans are going out to the
world yeah oh you know what I didn't
even think of this a girl that's had one
one night stand five bodies or ten
bodies all relationships
why would she need 10 relationships okay
well we could we could change the number
the concept is how yeah how old is she I
don't think she should even be on the
scale the relationship happen is no good
that's all right yeah yeah but how old
is she to have 10 relationships [__] me
probably 30 35 and miserable
[Laughter]
[Music]
high body counter single mother oh yeah
hi body hi body count okay all right you
gotta pick one all right raise your hand
you'd rather date a high body count over
a single
mothers
all right yeah but then you gotta have a
camera single mother over high body
count yeah all right there's more men
that would take the kid I think right
yeah okay yeah all right so sing
the worst hi wait no wait
hi
body count because if the context is
actually like getting into a
relationship with her yeah what so you
have to become step daddy no yeah like
like I'd rather take a girl with a high
body count and like it's gonna be my kid
then I'm looking after some other man's
ejaculate yeah like what the [__] is
that my responsibility I'm glad that
yeah you have no responsibility for
somebody else's kid ever but then you do
find a lot and I wouldn't have authority
over him either when I was on dating a
little while ago there was a lot of men
just looking purely for single mums and
my mum gets a lot of stuff on Tina my
mom okay
she's ready
hookers only fans strippers high body
count single mothers low body count
right yeah
at the top of the pyramid can you just
put version
I figured that was okay okay yeah we
love 12 year olds
we're literally the Catholic Church yes
yeah wow so this is the oh my gosh I'm
gonna spell it wrong I already know
hierarchy
you are very creative great job
[Applause]
so team effort it was a team effort we
did really well so
um
yeah yeah
I am a little surprised you guys put
only fans of below strippers I wasn't
sure you guys were gonna go for that I
think if we're talking about the
standard stripper that just takes their
clothes off and doesn't have sex for
money then yeah yeah yeah because it
depends I think working in this world
have been and only fans you know that
some people are going to do some things
and some people aren't good so yeah
there's different levels so what made
you guys do only fans instead of like
working at McDonald's or something
right to
like Starbucks Costa and honestly I
couldn't think of anything worse than
paying someone else's bills last year I
was at I was skiing and I saw my old CEO
of my old company and we were at the
same place at the same time and I'm like
I would much rather be here than working
for you
um and obviously I just like sucking
dick so did you go
so I so I worked for nhs11
um I was still working for nhs11 were
you like a nurse or something no I was a
health advisor and a coach so teaching
other people how to be a health advisor
um and I I did that job and I still
couldn't afford food and I needed extra
income I'd obviously seen only funds
around and I heard that you could make
lots of money and I started and only
funds okay what about you so I was in
university start studying accountancy
and whilst I was in university I became
a stripper just for some extra money on
the side and a lot of girls there had
started only fans and I thought I'm a
stripper anyway like I might as well do
it without realizing that it's actually
a lot different but no I'm here five
years later
what about you so I got my psychology
degree and I really struggled through
uni with my mental health and I just
didn't feel ready to go into that kind
of job that's so physically and mentally
demanding
um
yeah yeah so I I how is it physically
demanding well I don't know I feel like
you know going to work every day and
like having to do most people have to go
to work every day
deal with like having to deal with other
people's mental health and that kind of
thing and yeah it just seemed like the
better option for me and it gave me time
to heal my mental health so was money a
factor for you or no
um yeah definitely because obviously
it's unlimited earning potential which
is different to what I would get if I
went into an entry role as a cycle and
then it seems like you were saying like
flexible hours I guess yeah I have my
dog so that was really important to me
to be able to be with him
um I've been in the sex industry for
like nine years now and I got into it I
think probably because I've probably
I've been like sexually harassed from
the age of like 13 in the workplace
um so for me it's somewhere that I'm
safe
because I just imagine like nine years
being in the normal Workforce the amount
of sa that I would have experienced
whereas I'm in control of everything
where did you work well it was basically
work experience
I was like 13 14 around that age so I
did a week of that and the boss he
basically tried to essay me and I ran
away and like from then on I've always
had somebody in the workplace try to do
something towards me whether it's just
harassment whether it's what do you mean
by harassment
um like I worked in Amazon so I was in
the warehouse and this I remember this
person and he kept finding me in the
warehouse and he was like her boss
higher up where he could like check the
system and like see where I am so he
would always check the system and then
he would like come follow me around you
know and like just be like Hi how are
you like you look really good today what
a gentleman yeah no it was it was creepy
because no it was just very creepy and I
was a lot younger than him you know I
was like 18. he was probably like 50 or
something so in just that aspect it was
very uncomfortable for me and I've just
experienced a lot of that so you didn't
want to be sexually harassed in the
workplace so you did only fans yeah
because I feel like it was just
something that avoid it I'm just writing
this down yeah
all right
so was that the only reason in money of
anything to do yeah money definitely I
grew up you know a councilor State it's
a poor family
um I had somebody offer me an
opportunity when I was very young in the
adult industry and I took it you know it
wasn't the best start into the industry
but I'm grateful for like where I am now
so I don't regret anything that I've
done and I'm I'm just I enjoy doing what
I do I enjoy speaking to people and I
have a so many relationships with people
that I talk to who and genuinely care
about me as a person with like yeah just
day-to-day things things that are
happening in my life who are you talking
about like the people that watch you
people who are like subscribe to me so
people who I speak to every single day
more than you know people in my
day-to-day life my friends my family I
speak to them more so they have a better
understanding of the things that I go
through in life and I just have good
relationships with them and I enjoy it
it's fun
okay so the the number one thing I got
was money so I was like oh definitely
it's definitely money what about Andy
what how did you
money I suppose I'm an engineer always
money what I'm an engineer you're an
engineer I worked on the other rigs I'm
fully qualified and then you just wanted
to make more money no so um I worked as
a gas manager for the council and uh
before covert happened my preliminary
heat company went bust
um so I took on a Downy fans account
started a gun and my boss found out
about it and he fired me literally fired
me so blame him or no do you blame him
no I tried to Perpetual over his house
really no no no not to blame him but I'm
glad I'm sort of glad in a way you know
he it was horrible at the time I didn't
have it was during covet so I couldn't
get a new job
um couldn't pay my rent couldn't pay
anything so I started doing laundry fans
full time and now I'm super successful I
started my own pornstar University so I
teach people how to draw an event the
right way now how did we forget porn
star on here I know
I'd say it ranks pretty similar to only
fans really no it would be better
yeah okay yeah because you're getting
paid the absolute minimum
is probably under about 50 dudes
anyway so you've got no idea who they
are so the average porn star female porn
star shooting in the professional scene
sorry cornstar in America is probably
only shooting with about 50 dudes
maximum okay yeah but most people aren't
even like most guys I find aren't even
looking well obviously I have a lot of
submissive guys on my only fans but most
of them are looking at Dicks anyway like
they ain't looking at me they're looking
at the spunk that's coming on my face
why is it he got a bigger load for me
and I'm like I don't know ask him maybe
he's awaken anything that's why people
like Andy do so well
how long do you guys expect to have only
fans Thirty Thirty Thirty you're done
yeah well
I'm a little longer look at me people
always say that I'm expired now and I'm
only 25. I think there's a lot more the
thing is for me is that I always wanted
to to do something on social media uh
the only for me the means of money I
grew up with like literally nothing
um only fans is the only way that I
could fund certain things that I really
wanted to do and obviously I love having
I love doing all of the the dirty stuff
as well so that's a bit of everything
and once that time has come
and I'm ready to stop doing only fans
that I can actually live off of this
stuff the other things I do and the
other stuff that I create I'm like such
a creative person like I just so you're
you're playing long term is to do social
media yeah mine is exactly the same so
the money that only funds brings in
gives you opportunities that you
wouldn't be able to do if you didn't
have that kind of money
um so yeah I why what are we talking
though like you want to be like uh like
a digital agency well I've just made a
like a full TV program on YouTube
literally it's called the only fan of
anyone wants to watch it it's like love
Island
um but literally I've I it was it's over
it's over three episodes one guy four
only fans goals the production team was
massive Kimmy was on it Deanna was on it
uh the production team was massive but
you know I wouldn't have been able to
have the money to make that unless I had
only fans so you think like only friends
is a gateway into like a job like
so you want to put on your resume and go
to ITV and say how I can produce a show
uh
we've had Netflix and 2020 contact two
people who are on the only fan do you
think if you've got a job interview and
say oh what's your recent experience
today I've done some only I've said
stuff and hey yeah no I have suck dick
on camera but I've also produced
directed and completely filled out a
whole three-day show
and did everything that I'm sure you'll
be the front runner for the job yeah but
I did yeah and then if I stuck on top of
that you're not going to be applying for
a job though exactly that's not my own
job maybe no let me put don't let me put
words in your mouth but like what I'm
hearing from you guys is the money that
you're getting from all this only fair
and stuff is stuff that you're going to
try and funnel into other um
so you don't have to have a job yeah
yeah
it's everything I think obviously I
think a lot of like people we all love
doing social media that's the whole
reason why we're here social media is
great it's it can be easy and it can be
very fun and that's the whole reason why
we love doing it obviously I think as a
woman you have very normal needs to want
to have sex and do all these things and
it's kind of getting out that fun side
with people who are you know they come
to you and you don't have to have any
sort of commitment to them which is
great and you can talk to them they give
you money and then you can use that and
utilize that to keep other people other
types of people entertained so not only
can people watch me do XYZ I'm not going
to say it on here because obviously it's
YouTube but they can also watch me
actually have talent where do you post
you said it's like three only fans girls
one guy yeah so I post on YouTube okay
so you did that on YouTube yeah so it's
the third episode is coming on Sunday
actually so we've been releasing them
weekly uh we're doing another one in a
couple of weeks time
and then we're doing a winter one as
well okay so your plan only fans till 30
then do social media and produce
hopefully okay I'm hoping you see that
that will retire it's like it's going
into it's setting up your own business
as an another like social influencer
kind of thing or you just make enough
money until you can retire basically
okay um how much money do you need to
retire
today
if that's your plan I would think you'd
know how much that's not my plan my plan
is to go into Obsession yeah yeah okay
what about you
um so I don't know because I'm 30 next
year actually okay you don't look it
yeah I'm 35.
um next year and for me like a game and
I do twitch I've only decently just
started but for me over the next like
maybe five six years I just kind of want
to like the only fans is here and twitch
is here I kind of just want to like
slowly but surely swap them over but
like Emmy said as well but they're only
fans I would have never been able to
have like my nice setup and like the
followers that I have and things like
that you know but you don't think
they're kind of because even if you're
if you're gaming on Twitch like that's
still a young person's like a young
woman's game you know no one's watching
like 45 year old moms on Twitch
okay
me kind of makes sense like going into
production because like I've seen I know
some like I've seen like porn stars have
done that where they end up like
producing the porn lay it kind of makes
sense but like this whole you're going
to be a social media influencer just
logically doesn't make sense because
it's still tied to Beauty
like the the stuff you're talking about
is still tied to your beauty I think the
YouTube stuff would like be cluster's
social influence though that's what's
that's what I think I mean the thing is
is that well yeah if you're like
provided she could make herself look
like an idiot on Twitch by like throwing
custard on herself every time that she
kills someone I don't know but it would
still get views do you think is that
stupid well if you're hot
into MILFs like people call me a MILF
and I'm 25. yeah but maybe up to four
people like 65 I don't see you know
you're gonna live to be 80 or 90 most of
us yeah yeah we'll be retired by them
I'm not going to look much different in
five years old you know what I mean so
it's like uh like invest most of my
money now so like see like obviously I
do in the next five years one twitch to
become like a bigger thing I don't
expect people to like have 20 000
viewers in the next time but my thing is
you guys are going to live to be like
let's just assume we all live to be 85.
yeah yeah okay 85 so it's like what is
the second half of your life look like
lying on a beach enjoying the sunshine
but yeah but so I'm just curious if you
guys have a plan like save this much to
get this much money to retire like so
yeah right now I'm looking to buy my
mama a house cash out right because
she's been for a lot
and obviously them renting out the house
to her until obviously she gets elderly
she doesn't have to worry about anything
that's all her done and then in that
case well I can't have kids myself so I
can't physically leave houses to
children or anything like that but I
want to make sure that people around me
are okay set up my brother and his
girlfriend they're looking for a house I
would love to be able to have all of
those there so the people that I love
could I could buy houses outright they
live in those and then obviously it gets
passed on to maybe my brother's kids you
know okay so you want to invest in real
estate yeah
um and obviously you have the production
and all the fun stuff that I really want
to do you can do that up until whenever
okay
um what about you
um so I actually kind of stopped my only
fans a couple of months ago because I
actually make more on Tick Tock now
doing Street interviews than I did on
only five on Tick Tock yeah the ad rates
are so built oh no so I get paid by
Brands to do interviews and it's like
ugc as well yeah
um so yeah and yeah I stopped only fun
two months ago because I was making more
on Tick Tock you can't get paid that
much then because I get paid to do brand
stuff and I get like I feel like Street
interviews is like where it's up though
yeah but I've done three interviews and
I've get paid from Brands like Brands
they they give you good money but it's
nowhere near as good as only fans well I
just got my first five figure deal which
I've had five figure deals but only fans
still doesn't talk yeah
I only ever did same content so I don't
know
no no I've never I've never done
threesome on only funds no so I only do
like bikini and lingerie content on
there that's what I did that's right
because I knew that I always wanted to
go into something else I mean I did make
good money better than what I would have
made in a regular job do you regret
doing that now that you know you could
make money with the interviews no
because I feel like that helped me to
build my platform in the first place so
I wouldn't be doing what I am now
without doing that I think the algorithm
kind of picks you up can I ask like
Layla why did you choose not to go nude
what was a decision maker um because I
always knew that maybe I would want to
do something else and I know that
there's a stigma and that that can
impact you and also I don't know whether
I would want to go back into psychology
either okay so you're saying there's
long-term consequences into the
short-term gain for the money
potentially maybe but I mean I was
always mindful of that yeah people don't
know the difference
regardless of what you do most people
don't know the difference yes
girl they will think that you
sleep with everybody you have so much
porn on there and everything you would
have to explain yourself to every single
person that knows about you everybody
and I don't feel depends on whether
you're doing myself to anyone
so I mean I I have I have numbers on
that what what percent of men do you
think discredit a woman
for a long term based on having an only
fans every single person
I love being with only fans girls you
know the amount of guys I need a number
what percent uh 80 80 I say 19.95 yeah
about 70. yeah like for discrediting for
a long term yeah I'm saying like 90 yeah
you guys are all good good guesses 90.
yeah so knowing that do you guys just
like expect to like live the rest of
your life by yourself or do you expect
to get married
um I
don't really care that much
um no I mean it's not a bad thing I
think the thing is is that like you know
I know that [__] exists so worst case
scenario I could have a cup
it really doesn't matter if I really
wanted a man that badly but I'm bisexual
I could have anyone okay if I really
wanted so your your feeling is that
they're lying and like most no no I
don't think they're lying I really don't
I do but the thing is is that at the end
of the day is that
most people will be with you if they
want to be with you regardless of
whatever
um but usually that's not true yeah but
usually they will be with you and then
as soon as you break up with them any
men that have been in love with a
chicken they find out one thing
yeah exactly no but this is that they
don't dump them most guys will lie so
they'll get with you and then and then
they'll be like I love the fact that you
do any fans I love it and then then as
soon as you have an issue or a problem
that's when they're like you're a dirty
[__] and I'm like oh you [__] me so
that's your problem like most guys my
experiences like the opposite because
dated guys long-term relationships who
have said I would never go out with
somebody like in the adult industry and
then they meet me and then we end up
being in together for a long time and
they accept it because it's me as a
person that they like love yeah and I
feel like the type of guy that I would
want would be able to look past that
exactly yeah but ninety percent aren't
looking past that okay
I'll play Devil's Advocate on two on two
sides so one I I don't know if it counts
unless you like had a kid or you got
married you know what I mean like none
of this like counts unless you're the
wife right yeah yeah second thing men do
cap about what they'll accept I've heard
guys come on the show and say I would
not accept this that you know and then
you see behind the scenes well that's
the thing like like yeah like like the
90 of guys I don't know when the poll
came from yeah like it's easy for a guy
to have a standard behind a keyboard
yeah right yeah it's very very very very
different for a man to have a standard
in real life when he's got zero [__]
options so most guys have zero off those
guys are below fives right so working
working in the porn industry
um a corn shoot I even did it yeah
um what percent of guys do you think
would accept it just like from because
you probably would marry a course yeah
because you I'd imagine you know most of
the women yeah most of them get married
that's my that's kind of my point like
it doesn't like we can sit here and
pontificate about like oh what men find
acceptable what men yeah put up with I'm
telling you I'm just going to be honest
I'm telling you I've seen it most men
though most most
people end up married
that's not actual marriage that's not
actually do you know why I believe it
because I mean a hundred years ago uh 85
percent of women were virgins so men do
adapt to the market they do yeah yeah
but it's a Sterling's Point like
I'd say 90 of the time in the corn
industry
that's not really marriage though
they're probably having sex with
multiple partners if your marriage is a
definition of marriage very often it's
probably not a religious marriage it's a
civil marriage
but they will but they will be together
yeah long term and they will very often
have kids yeah okay I live happily ever
after and what about them that's
questions
that's all that matters they'll be
probably ending divorce and I have
daughters that do anything no that's
that's completely like not not right
that that's just a misconception what
about the people the content creators
that do it together like the couples
that are doing yeah
right now they're just green but they're
not doing it together they're doing it
with other people that's not what you
mean it's only cook if there's someone
else in the room with you I mean there's
a million people watching it there may
as well be in the room yeah I imagine
it's different no that's I'll disagree
with you there but I'd say that's that's
exhibitionism yeah
what you just said there were like it's
if it's like a couple making of content
and you said there's like a million
people in the room watching it whatever
maybe maybe
to you guys it's not but to me this
that's that's that might as well be like
[__] holding to me yeah so I like when
you get married like obviously it's like
whatever people are into yeah but when
you get married you want to make sure
that everything's like Secret
I bet you're into some real freaky [__]
definitely yeah definitely she's looking
at me like I hate you
it's okay you don't have to say anything
you don't because obviously not
everyone's an exhibitionist oh oh what
oh God the thing is we we work we work
in the sex industry so we see the
reality of this we see the reality of
people's desires but they will never
admit too is there a happy marriage is
there a happy marriage in the sex
industry no the amount of people who are
married no not even just the people who
are doing who are actually the creators
the amount of people who come to you who
are married and they will say my wife
won't let me do this can we reenact this
and I feel like this is where only fans
helps I I personally do not enjoy
speaking to people who have girlfriends
because I don't like the aspect of
upsetting a woman I don't like that I've
had girls message me before I've had
this girl once who messaged me and said
my boyfriend constantly Compares me to
you I'm like I'm sorry and I've said
this to you earlier and I was like I'm
sorry like that is a [__] team and like
I don't even know him but it's having
that safe space I think some people
still don't have the intelligence to
have the communication with their
partner to say I'm into this are we can
we try this can we try this and I think
this is where only fans comes hand in
hand because some some people don't want
to communicate their deepest darkest
desires and where they're behind a
screen and they don't so did they figure
out with that with their boyfriend yeah
a lot of people a lot of people will go
to their partner and say I'm into this
and their partner will go I know I don't
want anything to do with that so then
they'll come to people like us or
they'll go to other sex workers escorts
things like that and then they'll go
I need you to do this because my wife
won't do it let's be honest every person
on Earth watches porn yeah
they do but most they do most most men
but not so I'd say there's a movement
now
but the reason why the percentage of
people you're gonna project that because
you guys do it yeah I mean I don't
know that with one statistic yeah like
where does PornHub rank in terms of like
the most traffic websites on the planet
for sure
but but then I think there are a lot of
there are a lot of women I think it
women have been ashamed for for watching
it I think now that I do it I watch it
less because yeah
do you um so what's your exit plan
yeah I love the porn industry the adult
industry absolutely I don't want to
leave it
you could 70. why not
yeah I know there's a guy how did you
exit
uh covet happened sugar daddy
like what made what made you stop covet
happened uh everything stopped like
everyone all the work shut down yeah I I
was getting all these DMS from guys who
wanted like help like oh my I'm coming
too quickly or I'm getting premature
ejaculate like erectile dysfunction blah
blah and that's not helping them out
because my background is like chemistry
and pharmacology and [__] so I was able
to like plug that kind of so yeah it
goes downstairs together tell them that
porn is the reason why they uh
it's good I didn't I didn't understand
the ramifications that it had on the
male brain and the dopamine receptors
until I started hearing more and more
stories about it and diving into the
side if you'd like smoking like down the
line do you think sex work is a net good
or a net negative for society I think it
I think it is a negative
for the pure fact that I think a lot of
people think that it's so easy
and I think that I think it's a net good
it's a net negative on society
because the opportunity to cheat the
opportunity to think that you're going
to get easy money the opportunity of
people who think that they're they have
a stronger mind than they actually do
and then when they try it out they're
like I can't handle this and then stop
it like you know it's it's not a job for
the faint-hearted so like overall net
negative what about you um oh yeah I'd
probably agree with Bella to be honest
yeah negative
it's a negative sometimes if you look at
it from like our side but see if you're
looking at it from like a consumer's
point I would say it's a positive
because it's a positive for the men but
negative for the women yeah because like
see see a lot of my subscribers for
example how much do you make a month
's listening like um a good five figures
okay okay so how is it not negative for
the women no so
it's obviously it's good for me but like
I think it's also important because most
women don't make money on it okay I
think it is it's it's a it's telling
people that they can make five figures
and everyone I can make five figures but
they you don't see how much work goes in
behind that fight yeah but I don't think
Bill's talking about that negative oh
she's saying negative on society not
negative yeah but that's what I mean
it's a negative it's a negative on
Society for the pure fact that most
people
most people can't earn that much but
then majority but what they don't
realize is that most people on only fans
don't earn that yeah no you're going
back tomorrow no thank you I'm saying
that negative on society because it's
corrupting the youth it's promoted yeah
but then I think that's just general
porn I feel like with only fans there
are so many rules of things you can and
can't do I feel like the more the stuff
that I can't talk about on YouTube I
just don't understand how is it a good
thing to like be because everyone is a
sexual person every single person has
sexuality and urges inside
well you can do that inside of marriage
yeah but who's going to get married at
13 when they're starting puberty and
they need to have a wank For the First
Time
come on don't tell me that there is a 13
year old boy out there that's going to
wait till marriage to actually you know
they did it for hundreds of years
more admirable to have willpower
nowadays than to just yeah go to
everything online everything is just
yeah you know PornHub is the most
research thing you've got only fans
girls everywhere there's escorts
everywhere but that's the thing I think
willpower is one of those things that it
is important but it is actually also
um it can be very negative to try and
have retention
so the negative thing is that it can
actually cause cancer and stuff like
that show me some studies
but that's what I mean is that obviously
it can naturally happen but it can cause
problems to your project it will cause
problems within facility things like
that I do the same sort of content as
you right this we do similar stuff but
the thing is is that obviously the
willpower retaining and abstaining is a
very good thing if you want to get the
mind power back up and it's actually on
a on a on a level where you're trying to
um where you're trying to like
just to stay away from people because
you can like it's so so are you arguing
that a 13 year old guy the best option
is for him to look at porn at 13 years
no but what I'm saying is okay
okay
people didn't want that we wouldn't do
it yeah
I'm not asking that I'm asking that good
or not no I think it's not good there's
a person in here Sterling's a former
corn star we can say that okay he'll
tell you firsthand I'll tell you what
I'll tell you exactly why it's in that
negative it's a net negative because of
the ramifications that
habitual pornography use has on the male
brain yeah and his ability to maintain
motivation and drive and when men in
society have no or reduced massively
reduced motivation and drive nothing
gets built nothing gets I don't think
that's your height
Society
I'm talking about dopamine very very
different different things talk about
brain chemistry yeah but when dudes
shut up let me finish when I'm making a
nuanced intelligent Point don't just
blah blah blah blah okay yeah so when
you habitually use porn your dopamine
receptors get fried dopamine is the
molecule that that you get your brain
gives you as a reward for pursuing
something meaningful pursuing goals yeah
and you okay now we have an entire
generation of young men whose dopamine
receptors don't really work very well
because they've been hooked on porn
since they were a teen at like young
teenager and now they're not being very
ambitious
I have a question so knowing what we
know in the red pill that women are
going for a smaller and smaller
percentage of men
what do we do with the problem of
sexless men because I was thinking I was
thinking about this if you got I agree
with you but if we got rid of porn
tomorrow what would happen with birth
control still on the table because with
birth control no fault divorce we're
still going to have a um you know the
2080 rule so what what do you think
would happen with the bottom 30 40 of
men men would go crazy yeah you made the
point before it's like the reason it's
so like you guys can make so much money
is because the supply demand code yeah
right well and it's accessible and it's
extremely accessible but what you're
talking about is people who are
consuming porn that is free corn that is
free every at all points exactly they
get you through that funnel yeah
yeah but the majority of people aren't
spending thousands of thousands is
because of that that corn is free the
type of stuff the type of people that
will have addictions and things that
they will continuously watch is because
it's free again
see that every single guy who was paying
you a thousand dollars a month has every
guy spending a thousands no I don't say
that listen I said every guy who has
spent thousands of dollars a month with
you has also watched a copious amount of
porn yeah I can guarantee you so so I've
got a subscriber that came to me and he
said he he might be lying I don't know
but he said that basically he doesn't
watch mainstream porn because he doesn't
know if them people have given full
consent so he will not watch mainstream
porn so he he's yeah
so so he's come to me so I would say
that there is people that that wouldn't
watch mainstream porn not not like 100
of people like yeah
that's an exception it's not the rule
though because all the guys going on
yeah
oh I want to make sure I do it no no way
no one actually wants to do that so you
were talking about the a the 80 20 so
with with contraception so are you
talking about the fact that obviously
majority of people are having sex with
intent of having a child no okay so what
so I was talking about how women select
for a very small percentage of men
especially especially especially in our
20s when we have the most amazing
collections 100 of women want 20 percent
of men yeah they might expand in their
30s when they have less choice but but
especially in our 20s we go first yeah
so if we're if we have like fours five
six sevens eights nines and tens going
for the top 20. it's hard going for the
top 20 then what are the bottom that's
what they're cinnamon gonna do nothing
yeah
but wait wait so the problem is in
societies though is that when you have a
large group of sexless men like a lot of
times they get aggressive
the only the only logical solution to
the fix like let's say let's say yeah
because the the fix to the sexist form
of man is
adult content right yeah that's the
that's the current fix yeah let's take
if we take away that fix right we also
have to take away the Cause right and
the cause is things like Instagram and
dating apps
I would go a step further I would ban
divorce and birth control yeah
[Music]
who sang sexless men is a problem
where is that no no I think it's a
problem
because the thing is well the problem is
in in history usually when there's a
large group of sexless men there was
some sort of Uprising yeah that's like
there's even I've even heard you sign a
correlation with history yeah yeah I'm
saying
now the reason there isn't that is
because we have porn and I'm saying if
you took away the porn what would happen
to the sexless men do you think they
would I think they would go upstairs
and say they'd be more productive people
things would begin no that would be
crazy
I agree men and women the problem is the
society we still have dating apps so
even if like those men got better like
women would still go for the time
exactly because we have birth control
and dating apps so and no fault divorce
and so yeah yeah there's the point the
point I was making about like habitual
Point use leads to a reduced driving men
that's what that's one point the point
Pearl's gonna make here right now is
like okay well if we took away porn yeah
now there's a bunch of dudes who don't
have enough have any dating options
whatsoever and if they are frustrated
then they will they will burn the
society down
and you're right that it may not happen
but again if we look at history there
are traps yes yes if no porn is a Net
game yeah on society
that's why I would argue we gotta ban
birth control no fault divorce and maybe
take away the vote too but I don't I
don't know if society's gonna get behind
that yeah that's a little of the ticket
repeal the 19th you're an American you
can vote if you can give a president
you know what I would do I would I would
um I would run for president and then I
would win and then I would be like I'm a
woman I shouldn't even be here
I feel like I need to step down my VP
because I would repeal the 19th I'd be
like get women out of politics there you
go VP yeah maybe maybe I'll get Trump
back in office
um Okay so
we got everyone who did anyone say you
say net positive for for porn okay why
do you think it's a net positive because
obviously all the porn stars are earn
money okay so for you guys it's good
yeah it's great for us and then it's
obviously like Society so Society needs
it okay why
event
because a lot a lot of people are
sexually frustrated okay and they need
to vent and like a lot of people who
would potentially
attack women
you know they
you know I mean they need to vent and a
lot of them a lot of them that watch
this fetish type stuff on the internet
that's the that's the getaway from doing
it in real life I think there's gonna be
trade-offs like you like I said it's a
net positive if you go without it and
what it'd probably lead to more families
which is I think probably for the better
one so the people with those fetishes
can do that to their own kids or yeah
exactly you're talking about you're
talking about very small percentages
because the people that we speak to
every single day and you I obviously I
don't you had only fans yeah yeah right
so you had you spoke to people who would
have these innate fetishes it's more
people than you actually think you have
these very very obscure fetishes
no which is what the argument you just
made however the argument yeah yeah okay
however if you took away everything it's
like obviously
like you have some situations where
people aren't going to act out on them
however if you took away literally
everything that they could ever do to
release that what are they going to do
frustrated
I think you've got a fear of men that is
unfounded I don't have a fear of men I
love men it sounds like oh if you take
everything away from men they're gonna
you go I just think you're very nice
crime
the average person is relatively a good
person I know I'm not saying they're bad
people I'm saying that people have cakes
and vegetables that can be better okay
but we've already discounted that
because just because they have a fetish
it says I mean they're going to do it in
real life yeah right yeah not always
okay let me present you with a
counteract like an argument you might
understand from a female perspective a
lot of women have a
purely a fantasy in their head of a
grape scenario does not mean they want
to be graped at all ever because that is
a horrible experience but they still
have that as a fantasy they might play
out in their mind what women you know
during that during masturbation things
My Secret Garden
yeah I stood that show the freaking
handmaid's Tale
the thing is I think
oh no I can't I'm not even tell me tell
me why yeah
oh it's trash it's trash but it was
super popular
because women are taught to no they're
not no they're not they're not they're
not anymore
High School curriculum it said you
should enjoy
it's everywhere and you're you're saying
corn is positive things
it's not just women men and women are
into this type of stuff yes
who are gay men and all sorts of men and
women and so I see it from both sides
people like it as long as it's healthy
safe who cares I agree I don't think
these women are having like fantasies of
being sexually assaulted down an alley
by um
we have to live in reality though and we
have to look at what women pick and if
we're reading the 50 Shades of Gray type
[__] it says something we can't just say
that doesn't exist I'm not saying I'm
saying that's stupid if you read that oh
you thought it was great okay but but
it's not about stupidity it's about what
did women pick and we have to be
objective correct and so if it sells
what does that mean there's a demand
yeah yeah I didn't say that makes us
look good I'm just saying that's what we
pick yeah it is you love bondage you
love being tied up and spanking yeah but
that's BDSM I don't think that's that
bad
Fifty Shades
but it's along the same Spectrum yeah
but Fifty Shades of Gray put such a bad
light on the bondage community that is
not the bondage community that is a man
because Jordan is a woman we gotta
respect the bondage community guys I'm
gonna Read Super chats for a second I'll
go for it um okay um guys we're in over
a thousand likes on this stream so make
sure you do like the video
um all right saying oh my gosh Thane is
back same matcha I'm losing brain cells
Leah Brooke the endorphins release in
the brain while viewing pornography are
200 times more potent than morphine and
more addictive than cocaine wow Rob
women these days spend more time in
social media that they've left reality
for virtual reality that doesn't produce
a quality partner any more than a man
finds a good wife by watching corn a Ron
Martinez Psy the only the of money might
lead you to do things you normally
wouldn't be allowed to do but it's at
the cost of your dignity and ability to
find a man in the future
doesn't pay bills one who would have
allowed you to retire without of Shame
Adam Sutton nipple piercing lately lady
Pearl is not popular because she's
controversial she's popular because she
dares to point out how good average men
have their resources extracted by women
like you Adam Sutton nipple piercings
lady
um oh wait he put the same one twice
um Andre
um ferrarios guys wait time guys done um
oaf fans doesn't deserve commitment
image kills career Dr David Baker
Australia on the panel represents
tank if my sin on Twitter means anything
that apparently dishwasher is the worst
insult who knew
um Sancho's B I love them [__] I love
my 304s but I ain't gonna dump no baby
into them that's just trifling to do
that to my daughter sorry girls that's
hush are you sad wait let me Let me
refresh it one more time
um okay
I'm debating which question I want to do
next
um can we do the dignity one I want to
know who's not poopier things I'm
paranoid though
um no so my question is have you guys
thought about
like what effects that would have on
when you guys have kids I have got kids
okay I've got three how old are they 17
14 and five okay and they're they're
cool with it yeah they what those they
wasn't at first um I've been doing it
for two years
um but now my job gives them
opportunities that I wouldn't be able to
give them before
um I I was literally using food banks
with my children when I had my other job
and that that was a respected job
um I was still spending time away from
home like working and still coming home
and have not having enough money to like
support them now I'm home all of the
time they get all of my attention and
I'm still able to provide and pay for
things that I wouldn't be able to do
like just like an example is like
swimming lessons for my daughter I would
never ever have been able to afford
swimming lessons something so basic and
simple that's going to help her in the
long run I wouldn't have been able to do
that before without what do you what do
you tell them when they say Mommy what
do you do for work they know what I do
for work well obviously youngest doesn't
know what I do for work but the two
older one do know what I do for work did
to any of uh their mates at school
subscribe obviously not all under yeah
under 18. that's not going to stop
anyone from going on the internet yeah
it does because there's a paywall for a
reason like it's to stop like under 18s
getting access to it yeah that'll work
that'll work yeah that doesn't actually
stop
yeah I got it come on what did your son
say when you first did it
um not a lot really
um he just accepts that that's where the
money comes from and he's he's got a
lifestyle that he's happy with do you
think that's going to set him back a
little bit because he just thinks Ah
that's a good way to make money
um so my daughter's 17 so my oldest is
17. she's she's a girl
um like she she would never ever do any
fun she's not that kind of person she's
really shine reserved
um but
she's like she's she's happier now that
I do only Fun Since
would you be okay with her doing it
um I literally would support her in
anything she wanted to do I like
encourage it I wouldn't encourage it I
wouldn't encourage anybody to do
anything just because it's it's it's
hard work you do have the negative stuff
I'm not naive I don't think that only
fans is like the be-all and end-all and
is is amazing so if you if you said this
there's a good route to go down or a bad
route would you say it's bad it depends
on which way you look at it so it is a
bad Road it depends it depends like if
you're if you're going to get like 130 a
month then I don't see the point in
doing it it's a good route if you make
enough money
I I would say so yeah because I don't
think like money should have any bearing
on value unfortunately no I I disagree I
don't think it does literally makes the
world go round no I think there's either
things you would do for money or things
you wouldn't like like okay I'll give
you a different example like murder
could you murder someone if they pay you
enough money yes because
I don't know
your reputation will in fact it will
hurt your family someday it won't
there's always there's always what if
what if your daughters to get bullied
because their mum chose that route then
we need to sort the bullies out now that
our country and live
like if you think it's okay for bullies
to bully people because of we don't I
don't think it's okay I just know that's
an outcome it's a possibility and then
okay I gotta get a mansion but that's to
Pearl's Point not everything is about
money not everything is so material you
you got to have something fulfilling in
your life and to teach your kids say hey
it's okay you can if all goes to [__]
just jump on only fans and sell your
body you know I don't think that's a
really good way to I'm not I'm not a
parent so I wouldn't they can't really
go out and say it but I think that's a
healthy way to bring up your child I
feel like I'm in a position where I'm
able to support my daughter to not do
only fun she I I've got enough money to
be able to set her up her own business
so she can be a businesswoman and not
work for anybody else and slave away and
get minimum wage for nothing where is it
and you don't have to answer this if you
don't want but where where's the Dad
um the dad's an [__]
um can we get a pulp pill where are the
fathers uh for all the only fans girls
so when I was with him I wasn't even
allowed I'm not even allowed Facebook I
wasn't allowed any social media
whatsoever he was really controlling it
was another good relationship no social
media no social media that's reasonable
I wasn't I wasn't even allowed to wear
my hair down that's how controlling he
was yeah I wasn't allowed to shower
without his permission my mom didn't
give me a phone till I was like in year
nine I might I had it really hard you
know geez because I hate my mum for that
I just want to point something out I
think I think it's a dangerous Society
we live in when parents
allow kids to set the standard for their
morality I think it's appearance duty to
set the standard for what morality is
going to be in their household and
should not depend on what their children
feel about it exactly you see you see
the thing is I don't I obviously I don't
disagree with only fans so if she wanted
to go and do only funds I would 100
supporter
um I just it seems like you but you
wouldn't encourage it though no I
wouldn't encourage you I would encourage
you to take other routes um I wouldn't
also encourage her to go and get a job
at McDonald's because I don't want her
to do that either
um so it's it works both ways
jeez how would kids feel if you had no
money in the household
that's exactly how it is but he had nice
tits to get out so
like I don't know are you used to travel
a lot when I was younger and it was
shocking to me how like in third world
countries like they would be so happy
like they're some of the happiest I'm
sorry I was not happy when I was poor
and neither were my children but it's
funny it's in the west though it's like
in the west countries have nothing but
crime and violence everywhere what
third world countries well I mean I'm
talking about so I went to the country
I'm talking about was India and when I
went to India that's the most poverty
I've ever seen in my life like that's
the lowest like standard of living and I
um I mean it's both right there's a
range but in some of the parts we were
in and to me it was just like shocking
how like they were really really happy
even though they had nothing the thing
there's an extreme High grape over there
in India children I'm not I'm not saying
I'm just saying I'm not saying it's like
all sunshine and rainbows I'm just
saying I don't I don't think money is
the only thing that dictates happiness
it doesn't but in this country it does
and in most countries it does money is
like the factor that ruins the world
like that's it's sad boy it's true that
money makes me happy that's literally
how it is like you get more
opportunities the more money you've got
and you get a better quality of life the
more money you've got in this country
that's that's just how it is
I I mean I guess I really think quality
of life depends on your family more than
anything
I don't have parents well I mean I'm
saying
I think I think the goal should be to
have you know to like bring kids up into
parent households no no my parents do it
so like it's different for me but I'm
not talking about you I'm just talking
about in general I no offense I just
don't think that's like the norm you
know
um I I agree with you with that I think
obviously the the two parent household
it is important
I think having a good upbringing however
what so your your house obviously I've
seen your content I know the way it
works
um your science is that obviously
the are you thinking that both parents
should work or just the the father
should work because you grew up with
your dad well your mum was working with
your dad but then your dad did most of
the stuff yeah you know they I mean they
worked together my mom was going to be a
teacher she quit that too like they did
a business together so yeah so yeah that
was really nice yeah
yeah what's what's my stance I mean I I
think the more time parents can spend
with their kids the better exactly that
that's my then like with people like
Kimmy who's got kids she can spend all
the time in the world with her kids and
obviously still do she does yeah but I
would just think like the better outcome
is to get married and stay married yeah
right that doesn't always work though
and I I would personally my my situation
their father has a more of a negative
effect on them than us both being
together and 100 and the kids would say
that too are the kids are better are the
kids better off with you guys together
definitely not the kids witnessed some
horrible horrible things that nobody
should witness and they they are loads a
million times better off now that I'm a
single parent that's one thing I would
ask you though what do you think about
like couples therapy like do you think
that's a good thing like if there is
like issues going on with like to keep
the parents together if it was a last
resort would you come would you would
you think that couples therapy is a good
thing to make the the parents stay
together for the kids well I think if
you get a good therapist potentially but
I think 90 plus of therapists are insane
and crazy I'm not saying there's no
validity in the profession there is but
uh I I was inside school for psychology
yeah um but if you think the therapy not
well I'll tell you I was in it because I
just wanted a Visa yeah so I just was
like this seems like an easy degree so
I'm gonna pick this one most people
would do it because it's easy yeah yeah
no but that's not good these are the
therapists of the future
we're gonna go in and pay nine grand a
year well I had a I had a sports
scholarship here so it was it was you
look like you played netball volleyball
volleyball but but in the US and the US
I noticed like a similar thing I was
like these are the therapists of America
this is terrible
School teachers
you just found out I found out the
craziest thing this is very random oh my
God this blew my mind so I had this
whole women aren't needed in society
video I don't know if you saw it but but
because I realized every industry women
run it just tends to go poorly I found
out in the 80s yeah no seriously I
started thinking about it and I was
thinking one was education I was like
God damn we run every industry we go
into into the ground now now because
everyone was like oh you need the
teachers right like you can't you need
women in society in the workforce like
you need the teachers and I was like
maybe maybe we do and so I look into the
numbers turns out when women got into
um the they took over education in the
80s what they did was they made the um
it used to just be based on test scores
so you would have a test every month or
three months like and it would be a
standard and then you had to like just
test and that was it then they added in
projects papers all this other [__] that
made that made it more subjective
because when women go into an industry
we make it more egalitarian where men
naturally organize themselves into
hierarchy it's like a female police so
so now right now we have um the high
school graduate has a I think it's an
eighth grade love test levels so since
and usually there's a teacher and a
teacher's aide so two teachers couldn't
Teach as well as one man
because like based on test scores and
now we have participation trophies as
well
women yeah yeah because when women go
into an industry we tend to want to make
it more equal and egalitarian I mean
even when like earlier I was like we
have to like rank everything everyone's
like no we don't want to do it and the
men were like no rank them this is how I
would rank them because men tend to do
like more of a hierarchy where women
want it to be more equal yeah the same
in the workplace same for female police
they've got to get lower test scores to
get inside I think we should ban female
families yeah I agree with you in in the
UK police only get paid 23 Grand a year
so I don't think anybody if we get rid
of the women maybe they'd get paid a
little more I doubt that in the streets
maybe they'll get paid more in the UK UK
police is a joke yeah UK plays all my
family are police my granddad was very
high up in the police and it is only in
the last sort of like we should give
them guns too but that's a difference oh
yeah everybody yeah
way back in the day they used to have
guns like my granddad used to have a gun
they should bring it back yeah
definitely like while one of my uncles
going to Saudi Arabia at the moment they
will have guns out there
[Laughter]
okay maybe maybe not too much I don't
know actually I know someone that grew
up there and he was saying it's like
different than everyone says it is yeah
it's like when I went to Mexico everyone
was like oh my God it's so bad and I was
just like you just need to be polite and
be nice to everyone that speaks to you
and you know you need to be respectful
of their culture and the things that
they do and then you're fine I think
most people like get so scared scare
mongered by certain places it's like
like Deanna she grew up in Latvia and I
think yeah like people talk about um
USSR run countries and they're like like
it's not like so so my next question is
who is to blame for modern relationships
men or women women women
tell me why
okay we're too emotional yeah
I don't get what you mean by blame like
I don't okay I'll give you some numbers
so essentially essentially a hundred
years ago 85 percent of people were
married
or actually I think it was 90. it was it
was 85 to 90 because 85 was The
Virginity rate okay but let's say 90 of
people were married 100 years ago now
the average marriage is eight years
and there's a 50 divorce rate
wow so
who is to blame for this shift where it
used to be you get married you stay
married now
divorce I would say I'd say women
because yeah because they ultimately the
decision makers yeah not not in an
outside
I mean to you know for sex for marriage
and it's a function of society with
everything being pushed on new social
media there's so much options for them
and they're it's very easy for them to
women yeah that's the thing women don't
take the bare minimum women expect more
and that's that's probably why
take the woman the woman's side for one
second I think as a woman you can't
expect the world okay I really do and I
think
if you offer or bring anything to the
table but I think the average tick
really doesn't unfortunately I hear
women throw around the word narcissist
like it's a it's a game of tennis like
the thing is that not everyone is a
narcissist there are people with
narcissistic personality disorder
women's addiction to social media I
think women are way more women are way
more narcissistic than me and because of
social media the standards that they
they have foreign
do everything for male validation it's
all about social media wearing the
certain things and doing this certain
things I'm like all you're going to get
it's just the [__] out of it why are you
trying to impress these people and then
they'll do it and then they'll go why is
this guy hurt my feelings and I'm like
because you've given it up like that's
your own problem like you have nothing
to offer you've come to the table you've
given absolutely nothing and expected
everything and then you're wondering why
he's left you because you have nothing
that's self like self-delusion yeah
incredibly incredibly good at deluding
themselves yeah yeah but that
unrealistic expectation comes from I
think the feminism push women were lied
to totally for the last 10 20 years that
they are you know I would argue 100.
yeah yeah they're the strongest man
longer than that yeah that that you know
feminism is the way to go that they
almost unequal playing field to men when
it comes to certain scenes so to tack
off that point you said who the original
question was who's responsible for it
yeah well you could get really Technical
and say it was men because it came from
a certain French School of philosophy
that feminism and social Marxism came
from French philosophers really I
thought it was it was a bunch of dudes
yeah but the women are the ones the
women are the ones I thought it was from
Plato I thought that was the original
because his interpretation of the Bible
was like basically that women had a
higher um uh what is it called it's like
like he reinterpreted the Bible
basically to the point where like the
men have to get wisdom from the women
feminism comes with a boy
well no because I think that was the
1500s and you start to see feminism as
like a social movement mainstream like
the 1800s yeah I mean um so I mean you
know it's like if you go back to like
Henry VIII like and
um who was the woman that got beheaded
and Berlin yeah she originally wanted to
start the NHS like that that was her
original plan
like women come with ideas we'd cut chop
off their head like that's just the way
it works like it's it's things like that
I think women are just fine far more
impressionable they watch one reality TV
show and it breaks their programming and
they gotta think okay I gotta be like
this woman yeah you know you met you
yeah
you watch one soap operator you go I
need to be living life
think about it why are the ones falling
for it well because we're so influenced
they really last um they realized that
we could be influenced by Propaganda
when the radio happened in the 1920s
because basically what they do is they
say women this is this horrible thing
that happened and then this is how you
can solve it and they'll either put you
know vote for me or they'll put buy this
whatever here's this horrible horrible
problem they just you know tug in our
hearts yeah because the opportunity
arose I mean if we're talking about like
America during the war like they had the
um the President Hoover like he did the
Hoover chat so most of them the Fireside
Chats were women calling in and talking
about their issues at home whilst their
their husbands were off at War and stuff
like that and obviously the the empathy
would come more for them and then
obviously it'll be a lot of women
listening to that same thing yeah and it
would just it would just go on well and
they've constantly put like um
propaganda because again we literally
believe anything it's so crazy because
like even King we were talking about how
we do these shows and we just hear the
same ideas from women over and over and
over again and one idea that they put
into our heads is basically like if if
you trust a man like you need to have a
backup plan you need to have a backup
plan because he will abuse you he will
this and that's why like every single
show it's like the first thing
somebody's going to bring up abuse
someone's going to bring up this because
and then what they also did was they
they convinced women were abused and
were not because they expand the
definition of abuse so they basically
put God damn everything so they'll do
coercive control Financial abuse like
basically all these words to just
confuse you and convince you you were
abused and you're the victim and it's
like a whole system it's all social
influence every woman on social media
now is pretty much the same they wear
the same shoes they all get the same
birthday cakes and that's how and that's
how you can see like the reason you can
see women are so influenced by
Propaganda is because fashion trends
like women are so quick on to Fashion
you can see that women falling for like
micro Trends and stuff like that like I
think if you have like a safer wardrobe
like so we're all in agreement it's
women yeah okay
yeah
off the cuff opinion of it being I mean
everybody
no I'm just curious like like where that
was because I thought it was Plato in
the 1500s Jordan Peterson has talked
about that the original social marxists
okay like the guys who are trying to
conflate like because you know like
communism conflicts like oh it's the
bourgeoisie versus proletarian right
yeah and then social Marxism is it's
like men versus women oh I think Plato
was before the Bible I think it's Martin
Luther
of his reinterpretation of the Bible and
pushing out feminist values no no I know
it was I know part of it I know I heard
Plato like I don't know what I don't
know what time I could be wrong on the
time frame but I heard it was Plato in
the 1500s
um
but so I'll actually I am gonna you know
I I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna take an
unpopular opinion it is not men at
large's fault but a small percentage of
men's fault who gave women the right to
vote
[Laughter]
then then as soon as we got the vote all
the politicians had to cater to us and
what did we vote for policies that broke
up the family so child support alimony
no fault divorce and making things legal
like birth control but Bill how are you
gonna explain to society now to ban the
women vote well I'm gonna try
well I I mean I honestly think net
taxpayers would probably be because this
idea that everyone should get the right
to vote I just don't believe it like you
need to have some skin in the game and
the problem is women we own the majority
of the debt we're just debt ridden women
we spend all this money and then well
you can't just be some only fans go that
gets a vote
[Laughter]
like women always give up first that's
the way it is oh yes yes sorry what were
you gonna say I'm pretty sure it's there
was a certain point in history when it
was only land owners who were allowed to
vote too yeah
because the vast majority of people had
a
Farms that represent the household open
to ideas I just think we gotta take it
away from the majority of women
and I'll take one for the team guys I'll
give it up I can't wait you see tags I
can't wait for you to give it up pay net
tax like is in your attack like you're
more of a tax incentive than a burden
yeah right you contribute more to the
point you take yes like does it make
sense to me that the homeless person who
pays zero tax and lives off the system
gets an equal say in how we spend the
money in the system well I'm pretty sure
[Music]
like it will be all about it will
literally be even more about money and
the people that are earning the money
are going to have the more benefits and
the people that don't are going to be at
the bottom of the pile well I think um
that's the privilege with paying for
things it's like if you pay for the
lights in a house you have more of a say
you have more definitive ability of
lights in the house well yeah you it's
like imagine like your kids got an equal
say in your house that you pay for but
they wouldn't though no I know that's
the point that's why I would argue you
wouldn't but you know we don't have to
go into it depends whenever I bring it
up every time I can though
I know I can see you getting excited I
love talking about taking away the vote
that's my favorite topic
um okay how would you guys feel if your
moms weren't only fans my mom actually
spoke about stalling on any fans oh wow
um how old is she my mom's 50.
um the amount of times that my mom has
been on dates with people who are also
my age
um
what are socials uh
leave my mom alone
the amount of people who are obsessed
with my mom and she's like because
obviously you know you know every girl
has that friend who has a mum who's
attractive my mum kind of knows it like
she's one of those she loves it she
loves some people interested in her
she's like maybe I should start in any
fans maybe I should stop and I'm like no
please don't
I think obviously it comes down to
obviously the fact that people don't
understand like how actually difficult
it is and I think obviously the Gap in
the age where and the social media Gap
and engaging with people I think she
wouldn't be able to get it but
um but I I think so I would not Porter
would you say Mom start that off
I would say you don't understand
um I I'd imagine she'd get a good
following she probably would like
I would not collab with my own God I
would not hello that's not even allowed
on us that's how I know that you're
that's how I know that you don't
subscribe to anything so there you go
guys let's plug this guy for not
subscribers
no no okay whatever I would say go for
it if my if my mum wanted to get an only
funds and get her baps out she
absolutely wouldn't because she's a very
Catholic Irish lady but if she wanted to
Catholic and Irish too
I would say
my mum's nearly 70 so she's at the point
of life where literally dignity and all
of that anything nonsense literally
means nothing to wear anymore she's
gonna she's gonna pop a clock soon so
she probably wants to get into heaven
your parents as a Catholic did your did
your parents have like an issue with you
doing only fans
um so initially yes I don't even know if
my dad knows that I do it I don't know
I I literally wouldn't be bothered he I
know he'd support me like most people
think that only fans girls are
fatherless but I've got a great
relationship with my dad
um and my mum literally so she wasn't
happy at first but I think when they
realized that the money's coming in it's
at people's opinion changes curious who
made decisions in your parents
relationship
um so my mum and dad split up when they
when I was about eight
um but I lived with both my parents so I
lived with my mum and I've lived with my
dad as well so would you consider your
dad to be like a masculine guy or um my
dad's
um
I've just found that like guys that are
a bit more masculine tend to like like
they would have a more visceral gut
reaction like they would have a problem
with that where guys that aren't
wouldn't I think like so I I don't I
don't think he'd have an issue just
because part of masculinity is
protection right they're protective I've
spoke to my dad so before I started of I
spoke to I spoke to my family and I said
like how would you feel if I went and
sold some pictures of my boobs online
that's how I put it and my dad said I
wouldn't be proud um but I'd still
support you and I think that's probably
that would be his stunt still like I
don't have an open conversation with him
well this is this is the thing
I love these I love these interjections
because the thing is what you guys what
a lot of women don't understand about
Western culture is that the reality is a
lot of men literally have to say that
not because they want to because they
know if they don't support you you'll
probably go the route of self-harm or
probably still go and do it anyways so
most men will just give in to the slave
Mind program and support you anyways but
he still speaks to me he still speaks to
me I still have a relationship with him
point because he would rather he would
rather protect you from yourself than
tell you what he really feels and then
open up the door for you to go and harm
yourself because that is more popular in
the West in Africa
in Africa the idea will get beaten out
of your head
but it does only fans is it a disown
yeah I'd have to I'd have to destroy you
guys out no don't worry about it well I
would wonder who the hell I married
because I'm like why what like where was
it I can't wait for you to get married
you probably can I get invited if I quit
only fans can I get invited no
no no wait Michael where do I come again
my wedding I can go okay The Single
mother's in up okay so maybe maybe high
body count okay so do you want me to
tell you my body count in private and
then you can re oh you could could you
tell me now no oh no absolutely not okay
geez that's the hundreds then mine so
basically I'm going to the wedding guys
because my body count isn't that high my
body count is two that's mine okay okay
who do you on this who do you think is
the highest body count on this chart I
would say a porn star no actually I
would say hooker okay okay sorry take
out hooker who is
that after that I don't know yeah
definitely I will probably say yes
no because Sterling brought up that um
like it was a dude yes 100 but female
corn Stars no like professionals
there's a bit of noise there like well
how many times
is probably a lot more there's probably
a bunch of female of girls with a way
higher body count than a like mainstream
porn girl I don't think so a lot of do
you know how many girls in because in
the UK in the UK literally there are no
collaboration opportunities because all
the guys are creeps and they are not
actually real straight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if we added like one of those chicks
that's like just sleeps with all the
like a famous like an Amber Rose
if you if you [__] for clout you are
right at the bottom yeah so where where
did those girls
falling
I would say that the same level
I think they're slightly above hooker
are you for real they are they are are
having sex for clout even if they don't
enjoy it
that's jealous what do you guys think
where would you why would I want to [__]
a rich man when I already am rich guys I
wanna I wanna where would you yeah
definitely above hookah and possibly the
general of girl because there's purpose
behind it you know if Amber Rose is
banging Kanye West or sorry for what
reason though
popular rapper she's getting alimony
she's got the smarter out whereas the
general of girl yeah but you'd have to
just don't want to do that on the
average chance you're making no money uh
and then if you're a hooker you know if
you're at the bottom of the barrel yeah
but you would have to have a baby to
actually get any financial gain out of
that or get married which is a long-term
investment for little look at that
Mariah Mariah
I would think the return would be the
child yeah
I don't think so no yeah but it's with
someone that you don't want like so much
the majority of women who are just doing
it for the gain of money they would hate
their choice but okay so but the men see
it as above sorry guys the men see it as
above only fans yeah
so so I forgot what the question is it
was if your mom did only oh yeah what
about you your mom does only fans
no no no really why not no like my mom
personally my mom my mom is the nicest
most innocent like little lady like all
I want to do in life is like look after
heart of my little brother which is what
I do so like I'm doing this
so my mom doesn't have to do anything
like that like I look after my mom all
the time same is my little brother so my
mom would never have to do anything like
this anyway so I'll be honest I wouldn't
want my mom to do this bye why
like um because it seems like you don't
think there's anything wrong with it so
if there's nothing wrong with it for me
like like don't get me wrong like you
could handle it with your mom yeah like
I'm actually fine doing this like I love
my job and stuff like that right but my
mom is just an innocent little lovely
lady like I just no what if she loved it
too though wait there's something else
my mom my mom is an accountant like she
loves numbers she's so quiet she just I
love numbers too
my like my mom is just like an innocent
lovely lady she's just like sent in an
office like doing everyone's salaries
like stuff like that like how did she
feel when you did it so for my mom she
is just happy for me to be happy and
safe whatever I decide to do in life
because I'm an adult I'm 20 years old my
mom is happy for me to do anything
she's like as long as you're happy she
supported it yeah a hundred percent okay
what about your dad
my dad I'm not I'm not spoke to my dad
since I was 12 years old but we are from
Eastern Europe and if I spoke to my dad
again I told him I'd done he would hate
it and he would also hate the fact I
have tattoos
but we would release differently so
where why like did he leave or what
happened so
laundry and stuff but he wasn't
a nice man towards a child so that's the
reason he was a bet you know okay so
yeah that's why but like if he wasn't
like that and he was still around
because the way Eastern Europe just says
like this yeah
um he would not be okay with me doing my
fans or even having tattoos so it's just
different my mom told me no to tattoos
too yeah yeah what about I get it yeah
what about you
um yeah so I I do kind of agree so I the
reason that I want to make money is so
that I can look after my family and the
people around me yeah so I would hope
that she wouldn't have to do something
oh yeah do your parents know you do it
yeah yeah so my dad is a very strong
Muslim so he would never agree with
anything that I did anyway so um but he
understands you know we do actually have
a good relationship surprisingly he
understands that I'm gonna live my life
and I'm a grown woman and that I can do
what I want to do do you still speak to
him yeah we do speak okay so how do
how to send your parents money now that
I said my dad money no no no so my
parents can take care of themselves oh
no you said you're doing this to take
care of your parents so it just seemed
like maybe they could all right no no
not to take care of them but you know um
I would love to buy my mum a house one
day that would be like the end goal okay
okay what about you your mom um recently
I actually had a conversation with my
mum about it and I genuinely thought in
my head like oh if she made an account I
would be like go mom like you know
that's cool because obviously I do it so
I can't judge anybody else who does it
even though she would never do that
because of the type of person she is you
know she's very sweet kind
she's a very open-minded person and
she's brought me up to be that kind of
person as well but if she was to do it I
would be like go ahead okay so you'd
have no problem yeah dude what did your
parents say about you doing only fans
um they just basically said as long as
you're happy
and you're safe and you take care of
yourself I have a very lovely
open-minded parents so it was never it's
never been an issue with my family
okay
if my mum did only fans I'd probably
institutionalizer
it's like to see but I
I'm in the you've got you guys
individually but I think the common
theme across the couches is uh the
breakdown of the family guys have no
fathers in the homes no I nobody said
that I do a couple of people said that
actually I think it's that in a lack of
masculinity because it's so interesting
listening to you guys talk because a lot
of you guys that were saying they
supported you you're saying as long as
you're happy but that that implies that
and it's interesting's in the western
world it's like happiness is first our
personal happiness money is first where
in other countries it's more about
Legacy and family and that's more
important than those things
yeah yeah where I come from in Ireland
like when my family found out that I
don't know and obviously I do stuff with
both men and women so my family are
strong Catholic traditional Irish family
all my uncles I come from big families
like I have six brothers and sisters my
uncles I have nine uncles and eight
aunties and yeah they pretty much
disowned me straight away yeah and um my
uncles were very very masculine like my
granddad was
yeah extremely massive well that's
that's how I would imagine masculine
guys would respond but they're [__]
let's be honest they're [__] you
know what I mean I know I I don't mean
like not a personal thing but it's like
I I think that that's not a bad thing to
like disown like because that's like
brings shame it brings shame upon your
face
so I I kind of understand I totally get
it you know um
when my whole area found out because
this doesn't happen in Dublin yeah like
it doesn't happen this is where I'm so
popular yeah I was I was so surprised in
Dublin how Progressive it was yeah now
maybe but I started 14 years ago okay
okay and
um in the game yeah and I got my
brothers involved in my videos not
together but like what in my videos
um me and my brother we we [__] them uh
would you hey would you want your mum to
get on
um I don't know
parents at a young age so I don't I
don't I don't know what it's like to
have parents so I don't have that I
oh wow that's so yeah so and I'm the
oldest of six my youngest brother was he
was the oldest of six yeah that's your
parents at 12. and my youngest brother
was eight months but he just started
only fans
now and listen listen I I was against
this yeah I want to make sure I'm on
record but so yeah I started this PSU
pornstar University and every single
person who comes to me I say to them are
you sure this is what you want to do go
and think about it once you put this on
the internet there is no going back you
know this is not a get rich quick scheme
like the media portrayer
that's something I wish that was talked
about more honestly like you just talked
about it by high earning only fans
people is that it is not this get quick
Rich key and it is forever
figures a month maybe you did one month
but let's be real you don't earn five
figures a month don't listen to this
rubbish you know it's not it's not real
and did the mental health side of it is
crazy like you have to be very thick
skin look on the internet look at that
amount of crap I can imagine how the
crap you get you know I get it like a
sofa and Tick Tock you know I went viral
bit of fun you know what I mean but the
abuse yeah they do actually you see it
was just a bit of cheeky fun like people
said this guy's serious obviously I'm
not [__] serious it's a joke it's a
bit of fun to get attention does it
bother you
sometimes yeah when obviously so when
when I done this TV show this was me
ripping the Bandit off because for a
long time I didn't tell everyone I done
uh adult videos and
um especially when you're doing the
stuff a Catholic boy from Dublin doing
stuff for guys as well you know this is
where now I used to you do stuff with
like dude and dude yeah it's are you are
you gay or no wait so you're straight
you'll do gay stuff for money no you're
gay bro okay no no listen listen no so
this is a big thing for me if you want
to sound gay that's your opinion I I
appreciate that you know I mean that's
your opinion yeah for me I'm not
attracted to males I I get like he's a
good looking Geezer let's be honest yeah
it's great good looking user the
good-looking men you know I mean I'm not
physically attracted to them but if you
want to call me gay call me gay it
doesn't affect no I can't even um
so let me put it like this right let me
put it like this I worked on a building
site I worked on oil rigs 18 hours a day
Grafton my ass off and I was bankrupt I
caught I was walking around the
supermarket counting how much money I
had for food and I one one day I clicked
in my head I said this one never
happened to me again I will do anything
you know I don't sell drugs I don't I
don't have a criminal record I don't do
any crime I live my life in my little
bubble I travel I come back to the UK I
film and I travel again that's my life
no so you're not you're not a gay man
you just like to suck [__] no I don't
know
okay though so I let guys suck my [__]
yeah but I have done that's that's up to
me I'm a fully grown adult doesn't
bother me yeah you know what I mean if I
can do that what difference would it
make if you was gay anyway like it
doesn't it doesn't matter yeah he just
categorized it I'm saying some people
would view it as gay if you get banged
in the ass and for another bloke and
you're a guy he's just saying he doesn't
really care just does it for the money
yeah so and I know I don't look at
sexuality anymore I think why why do
girls care that you do the gay stuff no
so some some girls obviously will yeah I
think it's hot but I don't care
doesn't earn me that much money yeah you
know I I I'm not out slipping into all
these great VMS asking to film with them
like these other creepy guys I will do
what earns me money because it's a
business to me and that's how I and I
enjoy what I do I love it can I say it
Paul uh back to the original question
was I think majority of the women he did
say that they wouldn't like their mum
doing only things I wouldn't care I was
actually the only one who said that I
wouldn't like anyone to do any fans
people I wouldn't advertise any fans to
anybody no you know it's I'm not only
found adult industry in general it's so
pressurized in every single way that's
the difference I wouldn't encourage
anyone to do it but if one of my family
members was to do it I would still
support them and I I wouldn't disown
them but I wouldn't encourage them to
actively go out and set up an only fun
just for clarity who would uh want their
mum to do any events out of women I
don't think anybody
so how many of us well we would be
supportive if they yeah but you wouldn't
want it
I mean
I wouldn't no you don't want it doesn't
want it doesn't want it so we've got a
majority don't want it right
so how do you think your future kids
will feel no if I
if other women and the wise words of
Ella Brook they can cry on a Ferrari
obvious obviously my kids don't want me
to do it but they still support me
that's the difference the difference is
I don't know why they're not encouraging
me to do it they're not saying mum go
and do it it's it's they just support me
that's literally it
like I I wouldn't want my mum to do it
but if she did I would support her who
cares what your kids think anyways
you're the
bosses
don't pay your bills you eat my food you
live in my house you do what I say end
of you know I mean I don't care what you
think about me you're here because of me
you know you're here where you are
you're that private education I pay for
that's because of me but I mean if your
kids had a choice and they ask you to
stop would you yeah but your kids
wouldn't have their choice
that's like saying like I can do crack
who cares it's my house maybe so but
what people do if about people what
people do but and then people will have
your opinion on you that's fine yeah
would you if yeah if my kids had a
choice of to go back to the life that we
had or to continue the life that we've
got now with the job that I've got now I
100 guarantee that would pick the life
that we've got now they would not go
back to the life that we had before I I
could you answer this question if you're
if your child came to said mum could you
please stop doing only fans would you do
it I don't know I
don't know
if I'm making that money if I wasn't
making any money then obviously I would
stop straight away but I'm at the point
where I'm making the amount of money
that I need to better my life on their
life and I don't I don't know if I'd
stop or not yeah it just sounds like
just when I hear this I just wonder
because you guys could have made good
money on like sales or something like
that I made good money in sales
yeah I I
saw them you guys are all pretty girls
I'm like okay
the thing is
actually working all the hours so I make
that money I used to work eight hours a
week I used to work 56 hours a week yeah
working eight until six pm every single
day and I would make
like seven Grand a month right which is
a it's good money but then I had no time
to do what I wanted to do yeah I had no
time if I wanted to make sure then but
then it's like you could be 18. you guys
are like you're all pretty enough you
could go go get the rich guys you know
what I mean why would I want to do that
before before
well no no I'm saying before you got
down here
everybody
okay we're doing it well because I think
a lot of women just I I think you okay
because I'm thinking before I got to
only fans I would think let's go to like
some rich bars
order a salad like just before I got to
only would you not want it to be your
own money though no I mean what does it
matter
if your kid's coming to you and says Mom
I don't want you to do it and you say no
you know the money's good and it's
really if the price is right then you
guys value money and that's the best I
mean obviously obviously the case for me
is very different where I can't have
children however the money that I've
made so far I could invest that into
other things so I value that if I could
potentially the hypothetical situation
of me having a child who told me to stop
doing it I would invest it into other
things and do other things
if someone told you has a direct impact
on your child's life negatively then
obviously
no why would it have a direct impact I'm
sure there's more there's more parents
parents who teach children not to bully
other children not to it's not just that
it's not just bullying though at the
moment
on their life it's having a positive
multiple things like it could be it
could be uh their view on sex it could
be how they've used Society okay so
that's where your head so it's it's been
proven it's been proven to if that is
negative but it's it's been proven that
children are not taught about sexuality
enough especially men right no come on
no no they started in no in like the 70s
or 80s they started implementing Sac
said in school no but they're not
teaching men no no that's why men are
going out watching girls
it's not true they implemented sex ed in
like the 60s I don't wait 60s 70s 80s I
don't remember exactly what year but I
know after it there's a direct
correlation to the fact that at the more
exposure the kid has the more sexually
promiscuous they are there's higher body
counts more sexuality not lower I can
understand that I mean in my situation
when I was a kid I went to a Catholic
school and we literally just watched two
pillows rub up against each other so are
we going to say absolutely where did I
turn out like we got taught abstinence
activities
on my own I had to learn about that on
my own you act like this is such a big
struggle
like I had to learn it but that's what
I'm saying it's like it's obviously a
majority of people like are learning
like you're saying that it's such a big
impact I mean it's wrong like it's a big
impact when it comes from the school I'm
saying when sex ad was implemented in
schools which increased awareness of sex
so you think sex ed is a bad thing
I do because there's been more abortions
after sex ed there's been more unplanned
pregnancies after sex had there's been
like there's been more promise Q
then we would see a decrease in that
stuff but we didn't I think secretary
would be beneficial if we actually spoke
about STDs and like how what they can do
to people because obviously STDs can
lead to infertility and people just
going around obviously with now the
thing that we have obviously it's
something we can't help people are going
around having sex and you can actually
cause infertility in women which is
probably the same sort of thing as birth
control you know if you're going around
giving everyone chlamydia and then that
woman can't have children because of it
we need to have that education there in
place like or hear me out okay I'm ready
I'm ready
I bet you do that though yeah yeah very
I'm the born again yeah
respect
but I wonder how many guys come on your
podcast and actually want to like you
know bang you yeah no not nine
just putting it out there okay
but the thing is that you are beautiful
you're a really good looking woman and
like obviously I know that you speak
about the values and stuff and that's so
attractive to men and like I just I find
it so hard to believe that like you
haven't found someone yet yeah well it's
just just lonely things
your wonderful like the thing is you're
like you're like flirting
I can't put a baby into her I can't go
work on an oil rig I can't do nothing
like come on
in all honesty though I think it's
better to keep that stuff off the
internet to be honest so you know
oh yeah whereas I put it online you
don't
huh I put it online and you don't you
know I I look so um
um I don't even know what we're talking
about
um
what
I think I don't know if Sterling agrees
but majority of guys nowadays are
pushing more to the values of pearl yeah
then as opposed to what society's
pushing on everyone definitely that's
like the women's standards have gone up
and the guy standings have gone up it's
like an elastic band effect yeah pull
too far one way it's going to snap back
in the other direction yeah what's the
lowest amount of money you guys would
date
uh I don't care I've literally dated
people who don't have jobs okay so the
bar is zero
I respect like the thing is that I've
I've had such a thing around people I I
don't go for looks I go for personality
and that's always been my thing I am I
don't know what it is but I literally
used to cry in my room at night about
the fact that my friends used to fancy
Justin Bieber Harry stars all these
people and I'd be like I don't get it I
don't understand and this is well for me
too I thought I was asexual so did I and
this is the thing I have fallen in love
with people and it's ended up being a
situation where they don't have money
and they don't have resources and they
don't have I don't go out with the
expectation that people are going to pay
for me because I know what comes with
that if a guy's at a bar and he sits
there and goes oh yeah I want to get you
would you ever date one of your
subscribers never yeah if they were nice
enough
they're normal people
okay so you wouldn't or you would you
wouldn't I wouldn't I don't think I
think that we've got a relationship
where I'm online and they're over there
and yeah I I wouldn't be able to cross
that line okay and what about money
what's the money yeah um yeah but like
nothing I yeah I don't date someone for
the amount of money that they have it
doesn't even register in my head have
you ever dated an unemployed guy
um
I haven't dated that's the thing I don't
I don't date and I don't date anybody no
okay no do you do you want to not really
okay so you want to be by yourself yeah
okay fine fair enough go ahead I would
like someone with a job but that's not
me no but like just a normal job like
you can be literally anything even on
the fans
yeah literally but I don't sleep with
other people on only fans or just in
general I don't I don't sleep with
anybody who I'm not seeing or on the way
to relationship with would you date a
subscriber no no no because online like
I'm a dominatrix so for me like I like
to keep work separate from my personal
life so like I don't think I could date
a subscriber who I would need to like
dominate I would feel like I'm always at
work if I was in a relationship with one
of my subscribers I feel like the people
on the other side have this perception
of you that's not actually real so they
will see an image of you and they will
see one side of you they don't actually
know the real you and they they are
already invested in you emotionally from
the other side of things and like if
they was to if you was to date someone
they would already be emotionally
invested because they feel like they
know you and you don't actually know
them they are literally a stranger to
you I know like a lot of my subscribers
would it be different if it was like
equal like like you could also find out
everything about him online I've had it
where I found out that's like dating
apps though that's like dating up so
that's like dating someone off for
dating app okay so would you do it or no
no I'm saying like for the subscriber
because you said the issue is he knows
everything about you what if it was
Mutual like you could find out
everything about him like he had a
Channel or something no I feel like they
they they know what they think they know
about me but they don't actually okay
they don't know the real me they know
the character yeah Kimmy K is a
character and that's that's literally it
that's that's the only thing that they
see and that's the thing that they pay
for they wouldn't pay for normal mum at
home
yeah
it's a character it's a character and
yeah that's why I remember buying
joggers on yeah that is probably more
real like to her subscribers but to me
I'm it's a character
uh what were you gonna say
me yeah you were gonna say something
earlier I don't remember okay
um but you don't have a money
requirement not really like I would like
somebody with a job because I have been
with somebody who's unemployed and I'll
be honest in a relationship
the losers for for the man I would like
my partner to plan dates for us or do
things for us and stuff but when you're
the one who's making all the money
because your partner doesn't have money
they're not planning dates they're not
doing anything nice for you so you end
up in
kind of like a man's possession as in
like sure I'm like I don't mind cooking
the dinners for my partner like doing
all the nice house stuff and stuff but I
do expect something in return as well
whether it's a date once a month like
just a bunch of flowers but they don't
have a job they can't do anything
smoke weed all day why play Xbox and
smoke weed or whatever that's exactly
that's exactly what that was so after a
while after like a year or two you're
just kind of like
that's interesting if a guy plays Xbox
and smokes weed all day he's a loser but
if a girl drinks wine and binge drinks
all the time and is on socialism
you know it's not the same because there
are so many girls that drink wine all
the time all the time they're on social
media all the time
no it's just funny I don't think it
let's looked in society the same I think
I think I think Clinton Drive a full
bottle of wine every single night if
you're a woman sitting drinking a full
bottle of wine every single night
they're just as bad as somebody who
smokes weed every single day and get
stoned to me
it's so common like soccer moms you know
I mean yeah there's so many like
middle-aged moms I love you freaking
alcoholics
as well so what about you money
requirement
um I feel like I just want them to be
able to keep up with me
um I wouldn't say that they have to earn
like a certain amount as long as it's
kind of similar to me but I feel like a
lot of the guys that I've dated they
tend to like want to spoil me I don't
know if that's a subconscious thing that
I like but I feel like that's like it's
kind of what I tend to attract
would you date a subscriber no I don't
think so do you know what it depends I
feel like I go off the connection that I
have with someone so I would never like
rule it out but I don't know I've never
done it so I don't know okay what about
you
um I have dated guys who have been on
job Seekers allowance uh but so money
isn't like a must for me in my partner
but as long as you don't plan just stay
on job Seekers allowance then I'm more
than happy to be with you I actually
tried to stay away from guys who have
money but that's like my preference you
like broke men no not broke man just men
that no maybe you have ambition no
status like I have dated guys who have
had a bit more money than the average
man and and for me it was like a bad
experience so it's just put me off
personally
okay would you date a subscriber I I
think I would just because I offer like
girlfriend experience with my
subscribers so I have like a lot of a
closer relationships with people so to
me they are like genuine people curious
oh sorry keep going who I would like
spend time with in
person you know I'm curious do you think
they go to you more for the sex or for
the attention like the female like
attention and talking to you
um for me personally I think it's 50 50.
I do have a big attention where if I
don't speak to them every single day
they'll start having Hissy Fits and yeah
stuff like that no I've just heard from
a lot of sex workers that
um like a lot of it isn't even about the
sex like it's the companionship yeah
because a lot of guys are so lonely yeah
it is definitely and that's why that's
the plus of only fans as well like with
PornHub you don't get to know the
creators with only funds they do
um they they are actually speaking to
you and they get to know you so they
feel like they've got a connection and
that's that's the plus side of of to
it's like it's like online escorts then
what well the real fan the real fantasy
the only fans actually sells is the
ability for like a loser guy to talk to
a beautiful woman and not get rejected
but then surely when we were speaking
earlier about guys who are the the
bottom percentage I think there are so
many guys that come to us and just want
to have a conversation or like learn
especially for me for example I teach
sex education and on Tick Tock and I
talk about male and female sexuality and
things like that and the guys will come
to me and ask me about things
and obviously I will give them an answer
of as far as I'm aware or whatever and I
think giving guys that sort of like gas
up and I think there's a lot of male
influencers out there who are selling
some random thing on how to pick up
women when actually in reality sometimes
it is just about having that first step
of having a conversation with a woman
and sometimes these guys they need that
first bit of like oh I can actually do
it I can actually
speaking
about guys typically like what's your
average only fans customer 25 year old
normal guy uh literally one would be one
of your mates like for someone who
probably would sit there and go I would
never ever have an only fans
everyone everyone in the red pill space
knows that people cap because they'll
barking but this is the thing is that
like you know especially in the red pill
Community everyone wants that sort of
expectation and I think having that
experience of talking to someone
especially if they are on the other end
of it you know there's been so many
situations where I've spoken to guys and
they've been like I just want to have a
conversation with you yeah
and there's way more of it than people
being like can you um
those people are the 10 that people
brought up
that is they're the ones that would go
out with an only fans go a long time
they wouldn't they wouldn't
rank the guys
like activeness one
that typically you talk no it's so
different it's so different I've had
guys who are very very attractive and
who actually have money I've had guys
who are yeah probably three to five
average I'd say they're all average men
like the average men like average like
earner average
and I have no idea I know girls who've
literally had guys who they've wanted to
date because they're attractive like you
know you have no idea until you're on
the other end of it Sterling would you
date a fan
uh no but you know what's funny I've
actually had like women email me asking
me to take their virginity
so
have you still got these emails
politefully declined
good to know do you think you're the
only like corn star they emailed
what would they email me through because
of my YouTube so
it was a copy and paste situation trust
me
like was there like she's like all right
this little group of 10 will do
knock on 100 Doors let me get a couple
answers Maybe
do data fan
I think so if I'm being honest I don't
date anyways but I don't because I keep
my personal life very personal so I
don't think I work and I travel simple
as that
um my followers are a range of everybody
because I do such a mix so I have men
women trans every single thing follows
opposed to a couple subscribe to
what about you you still have a
following right yeah data fan
um if our values aligned
um yeah but I'm not not really inclined
to meet someone on social media or like
I don't use dating apps I'd rather just
do the old-fashioned way meet someone in
person
um okay I'm gonna Read Super Chat
um guys make sure you like the video
we're almost to 2 000 likes and all
super chats are going towards a kickout
cam we had a kick out last week we
really didn't get a good camera angle
Omar's back guys so don't worry he'll
kick it he'll kick out the next one
um okay um Thane Matra any Daughters of
mine would get disowned for thinking she
can dare ask if she can show her boobs
online keep your moral decay in the west
Dr David Baker Hoover didn't do fire
side chats in World War II Roosevelt did
Plato did not live in the 1500s
he lived in the 400 BC but Pearl is
Right Plato first wrote about the idea
men and women are equal in an unquote
virtue
um Andre I'm Ferrari what if a child
wants to work in gov I got so wrong on
that date she says
my bad my bad I tried women we just
think we're never wrong
yeah
um what what if the child wants to work
in government science or Pharma but
couldn't get the job because they found
out their mom was on only fans cap cap
cap cap cap cap cap Captain
to the blonde girl to the blonde girl
with kids um arthro Matt Pearl let's get
you cloned your brain and put it in
every woman's brain Dr David Baker I
can't believe this was even debated
grape fantasy is a very common female
fetish numerous Studies have confirmed
this approximately 60 percent of the of
women have them an average of four times
per year 15 having them once a week they
and matcha bring shame and shunning back
for a lack of morals modern society
needs correction Haram Bane um kids
being bullied that their mama is a
little literal garden tool some are
self-deleting over this modern mess
Thane Matra I am losing brain cells Leah
I'm the endorphins released in the brain
while doing viewing um pornography or oh
I read that one already Let me refresh
it real quick
just to make sure I don't miss any
um okay so I think we're gonna close out
the show so we're gonna do final
thoughts so anything you want to speak
your piece on you know any you know
clearly links you guys want to plug you
can tell them
well I'm Kimmy K on literally everything
Tick Tock YouTube Twitter Instagram
everywhere any final thoughts
um just let people live man just let
people do what they want
um go ahead uh I'm green girl Bella on
literally everywhere I've just released
the only fan on YouTube that song that's
some green about a YouTube and obviously
everywhere else you can watch me do
whatever whatever you want
um I actually love being here I I've
always respected Pearl so I'm I'm game I
love this so I have literally nothing
else to say I'm just stuck like I'm just
like why am I here you know what I mean
but yeah
um I'm Latvia everywhere about four days
at the end and you can come watch my
game
three times a week and my final thoughts
in the show and I've had actually a
really really good time and I love
hearing other people's thoughts on like
subjects like this
I just want to say thank you so much for
having me and thank you for teaching me
A New Perspective
my name is Lola London on everything
only Lola London and my final final
thoughts would be
um that is okay for people to not agree
with our career choice because at the
end of the day everybody has their own
opinions and
it would kind of be weird if we didn't
so I accept the fact that maybe you
don't agree with what I do as a career
maybe there's something you do that I
don't personally agree with but each to
their own and we're allowed to have our
own opinions in this life okay so
putting in the chat don't subscribe guys
[Music]
take me what was that link don't know
I've just come let me know right now
I'm Sterling Cooper I want to thank you
guys all for a thoroughly entertaining
conversation very very enjoyable uh
Sterling I I guarantee I can guarantee
you that all of their of sub numbers
have gone up and that's just what
happens on these shows
[Music]
and I have a bunch of advice for men
like you if you're a man watching on how
to be better in the bedroom for your
partner
uh names John Bernard you find me on
everything uh Instagram Tick Tock
YouTube at John Bernard K uh thanks for
Pearl for having me on again love being
here it's always a good chat final
thoughts money doesn't buy happiness and
it's not worth the cost of your soul you
know you need to get back to Catholic
teachings and family is wealth
I'm Andy Lee Andy Lee xxx on some things
and do it like Andy on Instagram and my
final part is [__] you could die
tomorrow you know I mean keep your
opinions live your life and just live
your own little but forget what other
people are doing yep you know what I
mean everybody live happy get along amen
sister there you go princess I'm really
proud of us for making this really great
China I think this is the best I think
we did the hierarchy of [__] um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um okay guys
um make sure you like the video on your
way out uh how many likes are we at King
like 1 700 last I checked 1800 1 800
guys let's try to get to 2-5 on your way
out to get to 2 500 likes sign up for
our Google form and sign up for whale
watchers if you're a fat chick in London
if you're a fat chick in London I'm
gonna sponsor one more fat chick pay for
your personal training pay for you
nutritionist there's a three thousand
dollar prize at the end we don't just
talk about whales we find Solutions here
at just for early things like the video
on your way out guys subscribe to the
channel we'll talk to you next time
[Applause]
thank you